cinema rules turn your phone off or put
it on silent mode that includes you
viewers trying to type too loud as well
may lean because like last week i i
didn't want to say anything but i was
like [ __ ] all i could hear was you
typing
guitar hero
welcome to this episode of trash taste
it's a little darker than usual because
one of our lights decided to eat out as
we uh used it earlier just randomly
just started strobing and it was not a
pleasant feeling so it's a little darker
than normal but don't worry about it
it's audio
only listen none of us have
photosensitive epilepsy because that was
like dangerous
yeah that was strobing like crazy yeah
it was full-on throwing so we're very
lucky that uh yeah none of us stuff from
that but anyway boys how are you doing
today
i'm doing all right i'm feeling very
energized right now why is that
i don't know just anne i i had a i had
mex no i didn't have mexican food i had
thai food and my stomach was dying yeah
and i thought i was gonna die
and then i went to the toilet and now i
feel like a 10. you took like
thai food doesn't do that to you you
took two shits in the span of an hour
it's pretty uh it's pretty remarkable
i'm not proud of it joey i'm not
uh it happens man don't worry yeah like
literally you know that like curry plays
near our house like
literally every time i come home after
that i'm just like i immediately have to
take a [ __ ] and then i wake up in the
middle of the night
it's unfortunate being like a white guy
who loves spicy food because my body
does not agree with it but i love the
taste of it i mean i suffer the next day
i feel like being white being southeast
asian being anything your body just
doesn't love spicy food like oh really
you get that as well no i can handle
spicy food but my stomach doesn't like
it
like every time like every time i
[ __ ] like chow down on a massive
fat indian right it's like a ticking
time bomb okay
i don't know i described like a fat in
hungary
and it's a [ __ ] ticking time bomb
like i know because there's there's a
local indian place i order from then
they do it like proper spicy and
depending on what time of the day i eat
it in
like there's a timer where i have to
wait six hours and i'm just like gonna
be like okay
this hour i'm gonna be just like
incapacitated on the toilet
that's just the way it's gonna be like
sometimes when i have it for dinner i'm
just like oh no
i'm gonna wake up at like 3 a.m
sometimes because my stomach just needs
to go now
oh man i just wa i was gonna say i hope
you're enjoying this podcast guys where
the first 10 minutes we're talking about
violent shits i just thought you it's
very relatable content hashtag
painful [ __ ] hashtag relatable take a
painful [ __ ]
question do you think it's weird that we
like listen to ourselves often
like because we have to hear our voice
all the time yeah i think that's weird i
mean it was weird when we first started
off right because
people at home have you ever listened to
your like your voice recorded you
probably hate it right i'm assuming
right i mean i've never grown out of
that
yeah you're yeah you're still if anyone
should be grown out of it it's you
i i i hate looking at my own like
hearing my own voice looking at my own
content
like whenever i do a collaboration with
someone i watch like the bare minimum
just to get what's going on and then
like i watch every moment of that collab
that i'm not in
i'm just like oh i'm in it skip skip
ahead ah okay okay you're like you're
like in the comments timestamps please
of when i'm not
why wait so why though like why why can
you like i mean okay
wait maybe it's the better question
asked why can we stand our own voice
because that's probably the weirdest
idea
because you just got used to it right i
mean like yeah i don't think anyone grew
up
right and like ever ever went into that
situation i'm sure every family had it
where
your parents would just be like you know
what there's nothing really to watch oh
i found some home videos we can watch
those and you're like
no thank you because i don't know i
always
[ __ ] hate it when my parents would
play home videos in france oh
yeah yeah yeah this is always me being a
[ __ ] idiot yes but it's also
it's also but it's also like the i used
to have like a [ __ ] squeaker voice
when i was like five years old
i legitimately used to sound like hi
guys
and my dad would always [ __ ] rag me
on me like man your balls really dropped
all of a sudden
and i [ __ ] hated that because when
you're a kid you're not aware that you
have that voice
no right because everyone is the same
voice around you exactly exactly and you
grow with your voice so you don't
suddenly be like
oh my voice got deeper unless it's like
a really
rapid growth like finally yeah yeah
you're just like your bull is just
[ __ ] dropped
yeah i i thought when it i thought when
it happened i thought it was gonna go
back
i thought it was like i thought i was
sick or something right right and
everyone at school didn't believe me
yeah but that's because your balls
dropped like a [ __ ] cannonball right
like
mine kind of dropped yeah mine kind of
dropped like you know this is just like
putting
like a rock in water it's just it's just
a very slow drop
that's a very slow joke well you know
what i mean it's like
because you grow with it especially if
it's a natural drop
then you don't realize that oh i went
from [ __ ] alvin and the church
we were really talking about the speed
our balls drops now yeah
so you don't watch the podcast at all
after we i like that
you don't watch trash taste wow i i
watched like some highlights
i i don't know like because i feel like
with me i'm just
super self-critical and i've always been
this way whether it be with my work
or myself and that's why like i'd say
like i've i've seen
anytime i see like criticisms of my
videos and my work i'm just
i'm more fine with it because there
hasn't been something that's been said
about me
that i haven't already said about myself
in some way shape or form
so unless i'm like super proud of a
video i really
i find it difficult to watch it because
i see all the things that
i kind of could improve on it or that i
[ __ ] hate about it
it's just out there i can't like so
you're too much of a perfectionist
basically
i don't like from one i hate the word
perfectionist but you are a
perfectionist
and i i like this i prefer the term
self-critical
a self-critical perfectionist is what
you are essentially
because like you have an editor but you
also
edit your own stuff too right like
everything yeah you always do like the
finishing touches yeah i always do the
finishing touches
and like when there's a collab where i
have zero control over i'm that's just
like i wake up in a cold sweat but i'm
not like
what if i just look like an [ __ ] on
this one oh you know it's
so wait so then how do you get through
your editing process because you have to
listen to yourself right over and over
and over again
yeah so are you just like cringing
internally as you're like ah i need to
edit this
cause you you're doing like you know you
you had jokes you had punch lines yeah
do
you not like think damn that was a good
delivery i nailed that delivery
yeah and sometimes i listen to a joke
and i edit it for like three hours and
i'm just like this joke's not funny
anymore
and i just cut it and it's it's it's a
weird thing where
depending on how my mood is my video
could just be completely different
like i could i could just be watching
myself and i'm just like i hate i hate
this part i'm gonna just
re-record this entire segment even
though it's gonna add like two three
hours to my [ __ ] video making process
and then i do it see that's why i'm glad
that i got an editor that has comp
that i gave complete creative freedom so
because i'm pretty sure you were talking
about this earlier but like
at least with my editor uh he leaves in
[ __ ] that
i would have otherwise cut out no that's
that's what i like i i tell
anyone i hired edit for me i'm like i
don't care how bad it makes me look yeah
just make it funny yeah like
please make it funny because because the
at least right you're gonna get the
draft right and you're gonna check it
and if it's really [ __ ] bad then you
can just tell them to cut it out but a
lot of the times
it's like oh i in my head i was i
thought this was not going to make it
into the video but he kind of
twisted it in a way where it's like oh
you know what that's kind of a funny bit
i never thought about
yeah like where i like fail a joke and
i'm like let me do that again yeah yeah
they leave that in yeah yeah that's just
a joke
i mean i guess it's like the difference
between like heavily scripted content
and more like improvised content because
there are times when
i think i have like a [ __ ] banger of
a joke and then i watch it like 30 times
as i'm editing it
and i have to like question whether it
was funny in the first place or whether
i've
seen it so many [ __ ] times i just
lost all like
comedy comedic effect to me the the
reason i asked that question earlier was
because i i saw a video i don't know i
don't know if it was a ted talk it
sounds like a ted talk topic
but it was something like people
everyday people should just like
record their voice and listen to it so
they can improve their speaking in
general to be more confident right
yeah because that theory was that your
overall
general quality of life in like doing
anything in daily life
improve drastically if your speaking is
more confident like if your voice is
more
i agree with you i would agree with that
and i think in general definitely like
if there's been the one big thing in my
life that has
done me solids it's it's the voice tip
yeah
and talking you know for sure yeah just
going at it i don't know
and i maybe think a lot i'm like oh yeah
i guess i'd never really thought about i
mean obviously
you know people say oh you have nice
voices yeah not to stroke my [ __ ]
dick but
you know that's the compliment i get the
most right and i thought you were
putting voices
that's the reason i became a voice actor
because people were telling me like hey
you have a nice voice and i thought
yeah [ __ ] you know you what you're right
i'm like damn
i do kind of i'm kidding because when i
first recorded myself i thought it
sounded like [ __ ]
and then everyone thinks that though
right right but then it's one of those
things where i think that
it's definitely helped me a bunch
because not only have i improved my
enunciation and just general
patterns of my speech it just made my
whole life more confident by
doing that yeah because you have general
self-confidence yeah because
because if i'm hearing it i'm like damn
i sound good yeah like
is that conceited as [ __ ] no no no no no
i mean i mean
it's it's just you just you get a skill
set by practicing it right
i mean like you get you get happy with
the ability that you have to like
change it and make it sound the way you
want i think yeah and like i feel like
even just being on trash taste and just
like
like i don't watch every episode that
i'm in but like i still will have to
watch like certain clips just to check
in and everything like that
and i feel like especially my speaking
skills has gotten a lot and better
i've gotten a lot better i of course i'm
so on point
as soon as i say that you really drove
that point home
thank you oh my god no i agree like i
used to [ __ ] hate
public speaking like in school it was oh
me too the worst thing
and which was weird because i used to be
part of my school's debating team like
we had like a debating team
and you know it was like groups of three
and you'd usually go against other
schools about whatever the [ __ ] it was
yeah we do not have this in the uk i
don't think unless you're in oxford
cambridge i don't think so
i definitely didn't have this where i
grew up well yeah i mean it was
literally just the three of us
yeah and so i was i decided to join that
because i realized how much i [ __ ]
hated public speaking
and how bad i was just speaking in
general so i was like
how old are you and you decided to do
this this was in actually this no this
was in elementary school so this is like
god damn sixth grade so like eleven
twelve-year-old jerry's like you know
what i have a deficiency
i would like to improve yeah i'm going
to do that you know you know what like
watching all those like squeaker family
videos man i was just like
i knew i didn't
so basically yeah so i joined this
debating team um
and of course like i was in it for like
two years but
i was still nervous as [ __ ] like i was
very fiddly and kind of
i had this really bad habit of swaying
as i talked yeah yeah like you don't
realize how many subconscious things you
do until you get filmed
yeah why you should record yourself yeah
no and that and that's what we did all
right so
my parents sometimes would come to these
debating things with
other schools and of course they would
record it just for memory's sake
and of course i'd be forced to watch it
during our
family [ __ ] you know family videos on
the 4k
monitor exactly
jesus christ i look like [ __ ]
schizophrenic patient
i'm just i'm just [ __ ] fiddling like
so my conclusion is
yeah but you were 12 dude i've already
shipped my pants at that situation
all the other like schools we went up
against yes we're just [ __ ]
chatter [ __ ] yes yes your honor let me
let me defend
myself and my colleagues right here is
like and meanwhile i'm just like
you have a point but no
it was that level it was [ __ ]
horrible
but then so i i tried to use that skill
when i first started doing youtube
yeah but of course like everyone's first
youtube videos it's [ __ ]
it [ __ ] sucks and you know i had that
i still have this problem to this day
where i say
like and you know way too much yeah and
yeah
people on trash taste the point of that
being like yeah take a shot every time
joyce is like or you know
and you'll be dead in the first five
minutes you have like a lot of
like everyone subconsciously has a lot
of filler words that you don't normally
hear yourself saying because it's
filler words when you say it you kind of
like fill in the gap yourself and
there are times when i say like a lot
and then there are times when i just
swear a lot as well yeah it's either
like you know or [ __ ]
that's my three words but also i'm
sitting there
right you know i'm a viewer right who am
i to be like
your company just like too much you know
as if they'd as if they have like the
most immaculate speech
who are you who are you to judge
it's like do you go around not saying
the word like ever
in your speech like with any other
people like i don't know i guess it's
because uh
is it is it i don't know i i don't get
it because i i i understand
that everyone has [ __ ] that they do yeah
they might want to change
but there's somebody my eye [ __ ]
why do you need to feel the need to like
tell people i guess wow there's really
something right yeah you're right
you're good you keep talking okay yeah
but um what were we talking about
yeah so like you know youtube videos
fixing your
speech yeah because i feel like when
when people see
when people see doing stuff on youtube
nowadays it's like the expectation is
that
for some reason the expectation is they
must know what they're doing they're
professionals right right and it's
really weird because
i remember the first time i felt this
was when i started to get asked to do
like panels and stuff
oh and i was thinking to myself i've
never been good at public speaking my
entire [ __ ] life
and just because i have this audience
this virtual audience on youtube
like conventions and stuff especially
expect you to like be in
like a top-tier panelist and stuff i'm
just like this is a skill i had to like
learn trial by fire you know what i mean
because my first few panels were [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and i felt like [ __ ] because i was [ __ ]
at public speaking but
because you were forced to be put to put
that
they forced you to be put in that
situation you just had to learn it on
the fly
but i do find it funny that just because
we're on youtube people do have this
expectation of just like
yeah they must be really confident and
have this professional kind of [ __ ]
background
otherwise how would they get all these
subs right like you couldn't talk
probably and they seem to forget that
we all started in the same place making
videos in our uni bedroom or our parents
bedroom
parent's basement or something like that
in my case it's a little bit
different because i hated public
speaking but i was always
okay in front of large crowds which is
weird you think it's kind of character
isn't that literally public speaking
no but he's not he's the thing
no that's the thing though it's like
when i was doing the debating team stuff
the most we would ever talk in front of
was maybe 30 people yeah
right and there's some weird it's really
counterintuitive but
a lot of the times i'm more nervous in
front of a small crowd
than i am alive i think it's more
intimate right like it's
if you have to do it in front of people
you know especially yeah i think it's a
lot harder because i've done like
because i used to do uh classical piano
and i
played live at like the sydney opera
house once in front of like a thousand
people
oh [ __ ] i'm dropping that like yeah i
mean i guess
that came out of nowhere yeah so yeah so
basically i i used to do like musically
properly yeah um
and i got the chance to perform at the
sydney opera house in front of like
a thousand people 14 15. wow
um and yeah it was just like yeah you're
playing at the opera house
i'm like like the opera house like that
that's the asian parents dream right
yeah
my mom
did your mum [ __ ] film it and then
like frame it and then frame it and then
put in like the safe and stuff yeah yeah
of course you did of course i
think one thing that really helped me
realize that should start not giving a
[ __ ] is that uh
and this is just in general life as well
is that like i think i remember who told
me this they were like everyone is
always
way more worried about themselves than
they ever are about you oh yeah and so
like
if you just think about it like that and
think about how you think about it when
someone is public speaking
i don't [ __ ] care if they're [ __ ] i'm
just most of the time i'm just sitting
there anyway
like they can just say anything and i'll
probably be like oh cool yeah all right
like unless they like literally [ __ ]
their pants on stage i'm not going to
think anything bad of them right right
so if you go into that mindset of okay
i'm going to talk in front of these
people
none of them care really [ __ ] it how can
i [ __ ] this up i
can't be terrible yeah but speech that i
feel is a little bit different because
even if you do [ __ ] up
you can very quickly try and fix it
right it's a little bit different when
you're
playing solo piano in front of a crap
yeah dude
just dude it's not classical anymore
it's jazz
when you go on stage do you remember the
stuff you do and the stuff you say
because i don't remember no [ __ ] like
like because sometimes
do you still get nerves when you have
like a big panel or big event
no no i get nerves right up until i'm on
stage same here same thing so like on
the like
up the stairs going onto the stage i'm
[ __ ] nervous
it's the anticipation yeah it's just
like i just want to get this over with
you know what i mean i just want to get
on stage and just do my [ __ ] yeah i mean
the reason why is because you know if
you're doing a debate thing
no one cares about who you are right
yeah yeah but when it's your
your panel right all the people come for
you yeah yeah
so i could sit there and salt them for
20 minutes they probably like damn
connor's exactly like he is on camera
hell yeah it's just as much of an
[ __ ]
you know what i mean like because i mean
that that's how you deal with like
hecklers right like yeah you just give
them [ __ ] yeah yeah
everyone's like oh that was funny you
know have you ever had hiccups at a
panel
yeah one time really yeah what hasn't
so oh god it was it a [ __ ] hentai
panel
and oh well that's of course of course
it's dude r18 panels i've never done one
because
it's everything i've heard about as a
[ __ ] horse oh my god i can't if i
didn't mention this in like the
convention store
yeah so i do i i offer to like
conventions i'm like hey do you want me
to run a hentai
dubbing panel yeah um and essentially
what it is is i just get a bunch of
hentai and i blow out the subtitles
right and i'm like
wing it right just just make [ __ ] up
yeah yeah people are [ __ ]
terrible at it yeah yeah and that's
what's funny but eventually you'll get
like one person who's actually like
really [ __ ] funny right yeah and
that's what it's for yeah but i think
one time i was doing it
and there's this dude in the back he
must have been like 30 something just on
his own
and he was just shouting cringe cringe
cringe the whole time and i was like do
you want to come up he was like
no and i'm like well get the [ __ ] out
then and everyone was like
golf clubs and then they clap like
everyone no
no because our panels there's always
that one guy who thinks
that like the panel was a youtube
comment section yeah
and and they always try to like be that
[ __ ] smart ass and
like throw out that smart ass comment
and it never [ __ ] it's never [ __ ]
funny you know who you are
i don't know i must be blessed because
i've never had that at a panel of mine i
mean
normally at those type of panel the
people loud people are good because you
could just bring them up yeah yeah
i mean if i ever put into that situation
i'd do exactly the same thing right
god it was terrible stolen the [ __ ] off
one time there was this hentai and it
was
brother and sister right and a brother
and sister came up to dub it
and it was the most the first thing i'd
ever done in my life
oh god it was terrible yeah that's
cursed it was so cursed
i regretted it and it you know when you
do something you're like this sounds
hilarious and then it starts you're like
oh no
oh no please stop please stop this this
is like immediate regret
you know what i mean they offered and i
was like oh god yeah this sounds funny
and no
no no no no no no i've never been
tempted to do
an r18 panel no i've i've only seen like
bad things happening i've only seen and
heard the worst thing because here's the
thing like if you come to my panel
like i'm i'm usually open to any kind of
[ __ ] question it is yeah but it seems
like when people see
r18 in a panel because i've been i've
been to r18
yeah they they asked [ __ ] that is not
like
it's it's bad i mean it's not a question
it's just
dab hentai don't [ __ ] do anything
weird yeah and if you do no but what i'm
talking about is like the r18 like q a
power yeah those are [ __ ] weird i
don't
get those it like i don't know what it
is some people just think oh it's r18
therefore i can ask them the most like
private [ __ ] yeah
that they otherwise wouldn't say i'm
like no [ __ ] i'm not gonna tell
you private [ __ ] just because r18
i don't care like [ __ ] even my
therapist doesn't ask this yeah here you
are
just asking about the most intimate
[ __ ] details of my life
yeah i mean i've never been on another
18 panel but i've seen some of the
questions that has
some of the questions that have been
asked on our 18 panels it's horrible
it's horrible
it just depends on the crowd doesn't it
really sometimes you get real like oh
god and sometimes they're quite funny
that's the thing it can be funny but
there are just some people who don't
know what funny is like it's funny to
them but then the moment it comes out
everyone's like
yikes you shouldn't have said that i
mean that's like discord humor right
it's like funny between you and your
friends but not funny to everyone else
yeah
most of the time so sometimes it's like
online humor just doesn't translate into
a real real-life situations
especially with a lot of discord humor
you know what i mean you can tell
when someone's been on discord a little
too much
when they ask questions like that it's
like um okay you need some real
interaction
man i i i saw this i saw this tweet and
i made me think about disco i know i'm
keep changing topics here but
there was someone who was like um you
can't be well adjusted
if all your friends are only on discord
what do you think about that statement
is that that is a take
um because i thought about it
and uh you know and and i i when i read
that i'm like that seems way too like
harsh
yeah but the more i thought about it the
more the more people i know who are kind
of
like i don't know and when i was the
same when i had friends online i don't
think i was very well adjusted when i
only had friends online
do you know what i'm imagining right now
you know the you know the picture of
that stick guy he's just like
yeah that that that was that was my
exactly yeah
it sounds so it sounds too much like
that's a bit of a generalization yeah
but at the same time i'm thinking
huh of the people i know who only have
friends on discord and like only have
friends on discord
um who i've probably like you know
especially especially people who have
not you know seen
anime conventions and stuff right it's
like always people who
are a bit weird in terms like how they
are socially adjusted and everything
like that this episode is sponsored by
honey imagine this
you make a list of gifts you're gonna
buy for the holidays and then
someone randomly gives you the money to
help you buy one
sounds good right well that is what
honey's doing
no [ __ ] way that is exactly what
honey they're helping pay for 1 million
dollars worth of gifts
even santa claus they say no more either
this is the money the real gold you're
probably wondering is this the same
honey that automatically searches for
promo codes online yes it is i can
say i can confirm that it is because the
script says so
with honey you can also make a list of
all the holiday gifts you want
from certain stores and honey will email
you when the price drops on
anything on your list just add honey to
your computer create a free account and
throw some holiday gifts from your drop
list
for a chance to win to win what well i'm
glad you asked gone because honey will
randomly select winners and give them
money to help buy something on their
list
you're gonna win the money are we
winning son are we actually winning some
you are winning son
if you use honey joey what are you gonna
add to your droplets this christmas
i want a ps5 understandable have a nice
day no purchase
necessary you need a paypal account to
redeem the prize it's only
valid in the us until december the 21st
2020 so get in quick
so you can get honey for free at
joinhoney.com
trash taste that is joinhoney.com
trash taste for all your christmas needs
[ __ ] santa
go to honey epic i feel like there is a
difference between
online friends and let's say real
friends okay
because you know i say this as someone
who has met
most of my friends online and has found
my fiance
online you know what i mean like i will
say that they didn't feel like
real friends like until i saw them in
real life i feel like that's like
sealing the deal
because a lot there's there's something
about having online friends where
there's always that wall of like how
well do i really know this person you
know what i mean and
you could there has been like plenty of
times where i've like connected with
them immediately you know you guys being
like some of them
yeah and then there are equally as many
times when i've meet them in real life
and they're just like
wow you were not high and this is weird
now and i feel like
i've been there you know what i mean and
i feel like if you just have that
that first step where it is where it is
just the online relationship you're
missing out on
a big part of what it is to you know be
friends and be social and everything
like that
um i mean i've always been since like
[ __ ] age 12
i would happily get on [ __ ] voice
chat and talk to like [ __ ] 30 year
old man
why did i do that that's uh yeah that
sounds
context so he invited me
sounds like that chris hanson okay like
when you put like cod zombies right i
would i would gladly get on the [ __ ]
mic and like
i would like bully these 30 year old men
like like i didn't give a [ __ ] dude when
i was 12 i would gladly like shout at
people like i would be no i didn't love
that man well i like the
like your anger like
my little brother was was too scared to
argue people online so when you did
start to argue with people online and i
was in the other room i'd be like oh and
give me the [ __ ] headset i'm going to
argue you play
so i would [ __ ] shout at them for him
yeah because he couldn't do it good and
he would lose the arguments i'm like
you're not losing the arguments on my
account right
over my [ __ ] dead body do you think i
will allow you to lose this
i don't know i would just because it's
one of those things right where
i would not fall for [ __ ] when i was
like 12 or 13
yeah the [ __ ] that they were trying to
pull right for some reason
i knew what was happening most of the
time when i was aware because
even from like what's happening i was
[ __ ] playing zombies with them most
the time mostly
chill yeah i mean i don't know i think
it was it was weird back then because
it just started when everyone started
voice chatting yeah i think it was new
yeah and it wasn't really weird yet now
it's weird if you do i think it's super
weird but back then i didn't think of it
as that weird yeah when i was a kid
but maybe i don't know sure i mean back
then it was like this new thing and now
with so many [ __ ] weird stories
coming out you've got to be yeah
now it's not you know if i had a 12 year
old kid and i thought i'm talking to a
30 old man
i'd say i'd like be like what the [ __ ]
you doing yeah yeah but like
you know i i get why people will have a
lot of online friends
because most of the time people search
for online friends because they don't
find that connection
yeah but it's it's the same thing i
would say as like you know when you
you can have like the best friends in
the world but as soon as like you move
in with each other and live in the same
house that
that like change can change a lot of
dynamics you know what i mean
especially you know you meet someone
especially in [ __ ] uni
you meet some people you think are chill
as soon as you move in with each other
you start
hating each other yeah that's true and
you see all their little [ __ ] ticks
and
stuff that just get on your nerves i
mean there was like a i mean i've
basically been raised
like on the internet right like ever
since like age like 11. i was playing
runescape i was doing [ __ ] on miniclip
like yeah
i was and i always did not mind talking
to strangers
because i always thought like i'm not
going to give any personal information
you know i never did
for some reason i was smart enough to
never do anything like that yeah um
and there must have been a good chunk
maybe maybe like a year in my life where
i pretty much only spoke to online
people like friends that i i thought
were like my friends
yeah it must have been the maybe first
year of university it's really weird
i've
i never had a concept of an online
friend until i started youtube
yeah like i never would get on to like i
feel like we were two different sides of
like the coin because i
i was always like i would always go on
because because in my head i was like
why would i talk to this random person
online when i have irl for instance to
talk
to well that's this oh that's the way
that you go joey's here's where it gets
sad i didn't at the time
and the thing is right is that you think
oh this is like because i used to see
those those things on twitter because
back then you should see these things
like
irl uh online friends or real friends
yeah mom you don't get it you know yeah
yeah back when tumblr was like you know
pink tumbler
yeah yeah and i used to totally agree
with that because i was like i was 16
that's all i had and then
after i like actually actually got real
friends i was like
oh this is what normal friendship
like it's like totally different yeah
it's something that like i don't think
you realize kind of affects you because
you totally think you're fine and
i think you can be well adjusted sort of
if you have
only online friends but it's a lot
harder yeah because i feel like having
that that irl
uh kind of interaction to ground you and
make sure you're not doing weird things
and you're you know
that you're interacting in a healthy way
right i mean because the thing about
only having online friends is that
inevitably you are just living
in your own bubble it is an online
bubble right
yeah and you live through what you
present to them yeah exactly right
you're only presenting
one side of yourself for the best side
of yourself you're not seeing every side
of a person
so inevitably if you just live in a
bubble you know you might luck out and
be like okay this is actually a healthy
nice
nicely balanced bubble but you know most
of the time
it you're missing some kind of that
social interaction yeah
social connection that you just don't
get online unfortunately
and i also think because i made a lot of
the friends through gaming
yeah a lot of the time how you were as
friends was dependent on
how you were in the game right right and
obviously i was normally really good at
the games
yeah so i was normally like yeah i'm
kind of i'm kind of cool you know
and it was one of those things where
online when i saw these people like i
was like
to those friends i was respected and
they thought wow this guy's so cool you
know
he just does his own thing and but in
real life i was a [ __ ] loser
and it kind of made this dichotomy in my
head where i'm like yeah i'm funny yeah
i'm charming and then i go meet up with
people and i [ __ ] struggle
like i couldn't i didn't know how to
because i hadn't really i wasn't very
well adjusted
yeah and it made me think a lot and
makes me look back and i don't know it's
like how do you convince someone when
they're in that
to see it like it when they're in that
sense of i only have online friends how
do you make them see that maybe they're
it's not a healthy relic like it's not
very healthy because to them they might
be perfectly happy and fine right and
that's the thing i
i think it's just a matter of
perspective right because to them that's
all they know
yeah so i don't think um until they
actually experience the other side
of like trying to begin and start and
maintain irl friends
yeah they just won't know they'll be
like why would i do that when
this is so much easier and more
comfortable and also i realized as well
that like
when i was predominantly spending all my
time online it felt like i could never
make any progress
in my life because i i was not investing
anything in
real life right i was maybe i'd go to
work yeah and i would go home but that
was about it right i never made any
investment
elsewhere right right i felt like my
life stagnated because of that
because i didn't you know i think when
you make friends i don't seek out
something else
right right because when you make
friends irl it's not just that it's like
you miss out on a lot of opportunities
in general like because you're not
putting yourself out there you're not
you're not you know
maybe other jobs you might hear about
you know other you miss out on a lot of
things i think yeah
yeah and it's not just as simple as
having friends and having friends it's
like there's a lot of stuff that comes
with having our old friends yeah and
like
you know i don't know it's it's it's
really made me think a lot
recently especially because like moving
to japan as well it's really made me
think a lot
yeah because it's been a year right
since it's been a goddamn year since we
moved here my god
already this is this has not felt like a
year at all
jesus yeah 2020 has been [ __ ] weird
to be fair
but how is it for you guys your first
year here in japan
spin i mean okay to be fair it's
probably you know pretty abnormal year
for people who moved
around this time you know it's it's it's
been it's it's been a strange year all
around
yeah you know it's i don't think i don't
feel like i've spent a proper year here
in japan
mostly because like i felt like part of
the experience i was expecting
from japan was to have people visit me
you know what i mean yeah and i had a
lot of friends who
had planned to come visit us in japan
and it just
honestly that's that's half the fun of
living in this country right it's like
being like oh man
i've always wanted to visit japan or
like i'm coming to visit japan and
you're just like
my boy i got you bro i wanted to be on
the other side of that yeah on the other
side of that fence because i've been on
i've been on the visiting side and i
remember how amazing [ __ ] was
when i first moved here and everything
was so bright-eyed and you could take me
to a [ __ ] family mart or a
combination and i'd be like
yo yo you eat this like katsu curry
every day
eat this fried chicken yeah because
sandwiches what the [ __ ]
just watching just watching those
interactions is like
so [ __ ] fun because yeah because to
you now it's just so normal but yeah
it's just so [ __ ] daily yeah dude i
remembered like i was at the supermarket
and i would i just thought to myself man
i remember when i used to think the [ __ ]
was like insane
yeah and like now i feel like there's
nowhere else left on earth where i'm
ever going to go and it's going to feel
magical
and i felt kind of sad for a second
because that is the final boss
because dude because i've been hyping up
japan my whole like
teenage to adult yeah yeah it was the
one place that i always really wanted to
go cause i went to america and it was
amazing right yeah i loved it because
i've always hyped up america to myself
yeah yeah and then japan was the last
place that i hadn't been to
that was like i really want to go here
because my parents took me to europe all
the time
and i was kind of sick of you that
sounds so [ __ ] privileged
i was sick and tired of traveling you
know it's no i mean my parents took me
to like france
every single year and i was like dying
that sounds like a [ __ ] luxury dude
we were camping in like tents and i just
like playing video games and i couldn't
play video games for three weeks so it
was basically being like
forced to be a caveman for three weeks
and like swim i'm like
okay i swim every day i guess but i mean
it was basically the last place i wanted
to go and i remember
the first time i landed here even though
i hadn't slept for like 20
hours i was so [ __ ] hyped yeah yeah
this is [ __ ] insane
what i can get a vending machine what
it's vending machines and they work i
thought i thought i would like i
remember when i like
came in for the first time i thought if
i ever move here i'm going to get
vending machine coffee
every [ __ ] day because this [ __ ] is
awesome right now i can't
[ __ ] stand vending machine coffee
literally everything that's [ __ ] out of
here just give me my starbucks like i do
everywhere else when you first come here
every vending machine you're like i
guess i'm getting
coffee yeah it's hot coffee baby
but yeah now you haven't you're like
this yeah do you remember when first
moving here and you're like nom nominate
which is all you can drink
like was like god [ __ ] it was like
earth it was like a god sense like
whenever we'd go here and we'd go to
like the izakayas
and we thought we'd be going to like
kinokura every [ __ ] day yeah
it's like it's like horde not even a
question of course kinokuro is
essentially worth the spoons i think
we've said that before but it's
very cheap very cheap tube yeah it's
like 15 bucks for all you can drink for
two hours
yeah something like that yeah but then
you realize oh [ __ ] i actually like my
liver
a little bit and i don't want to [ __ ]
ruin it and i also like good food as
well
and it's not got bad food but you just
get very average food yeah yeah you just
get better food elsewhere
because i remember like coming to japan
like everything i
i in my eyes all food in japan was
amazing
and then i lived here and now i you
realize that it's all
it's all good but there are different
tiers of how good it can be
yeah yeah yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna
wonder what it's like when i
when i whenever i go back to england or
something where good food is just
so much harder to find than it is here
where it's just readily available
i'm getting a pot noodle the moment i
get back bombay bad boy pop noodles
you should just like do the opposite you
should just [ __ ] commit and just go
to a weather spoons
and just be like i love wet the spoons
food well then there you go let's
but let's see let's see how it is let's
see how it is i i i [ __ ] with where this
means
food what i don't understand is connor's
[ __ ] obsession with the tesco
meal deals tesco meal dessert you had
one you had one
because i forced you to so tesco meal
deals right it's a thing in the uk
for three pounds which is about maybe
just under four dollars four dollars
you get a nice sandwich a big bag of
crisps and like one of the premium
drinks
you can get like a smoothie you can get
like an energy drink yeah but
yeah i took you because you got the big
big sandwich it's quite big and you get
a big bag at a crisp you [ __ ] loved
it i remember you were like yo this is
all this for three pounds i was like
yeah it's insane right
i i think i'm vaguely wrong and i really
like the sandwiches they make
i remember i had the weather spoons that
i had on in some kind of train station
and i was like yeah that was that was
pretty bad i took it i took
uh joey to the weather spoons in
victoria station it was terrible
yeah i mean i i don't think whether this
means it's terrible i like things on the
pub though
yeah it does it does but for the most
part weather spoons is like pretty
pretty decent for the price you get yeah
the one the one there though i was like
we were i think we were
struggling to find a clean tape oh yeah
i was always
like longer than actually deciding what
to eat yeah it was gross yeah
yeah because i remember when joey was
coming to visit me and connor were like
discussing oh what should we jo
what should we show him conor was like
tesco murder tesco murdo
i'm getting him a tesco muted i'm like
connor for [ __ ] sake nobody gives a
[ __ ]
about your three pound tesco meal deal
okay right i don't care
if i become a billionaire you bet i'm
gonna be eating mcdonald's
and [ __ ] tesco meal deals until the
day i [ __ ] die
that [ __ ] is value and i won't hear
otherwise and it tastes amazing okay
it tastes good i i genuinely don't
remember eating it like
i i feel like i don't know i'm hurt joey
no no
like after living in like after living
in japan and like living in asia where
convenience stores just have in my
opinion just good food to choose from
sandwiches in tesco are better than
japan i mean salmon just have like
mayonnaise and like ketchup and all that
[ __ ] in it
i don't need that [ __ ] okay you're out
of the question
where where does all the crusts go in
japan where is it where's all the crusts
gone i don't know probably for some
reason all the sandwiches don't have
crusts on them
where is it give me my [ __ ] crust i
love the crust i think though sometimes
i actually that's the reason i like
japanese sandwiches and some okay in
some
kid like you can't have mayo you can't
eat the [ __ ] crust on your
this man doesn't like it's still bread
yeah man what's what's the problem it
tastes good yeah
i just i just it's just it's just wasted
wasted bread that's like tasteless bread
it's it's like it's
tastes like bread oh it's the flavor
dude it's the best part
what's so good it tastes like cardboard
no it doesn't no it's what yeah
it tastes exactly like the bread that
it's like it's like the crust on pizza
okay
yeah why why does crust on pizza exist
and why does everyone pretend
it's good it tastes good no it doesn't
you eat the pizza
for the [ __ ] bread cheese tomato
sauce combination why would why would i
want to eat pizza
that is why would i just want to eat the
bread part of the pizza where when i
have pizza
i want the pizza part of the pizza okay
that's because you're eating it wrong
right you're going right up to the crust
yeah you got to save a little bit of the
sausage
and then girl on the side people think
of a [ __ ] psychopath when i eat pizza
the way i actually eat pizza at home
which is crust first i eat the crust
first because
i get i get that taste the [ __ ] out of
the way so more um
then how do you hold the pizza i just
hold it like like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
you're holding you're holding it like l
dude like you're like look look look i
i just saved the best part to last why
would i save the tasteless part till
last i don't enjoy it but you're making
you're making it tasteless by only
eating the crust
if if you save a little bit of the sauce
that sauce could be with the actual
pizza
you know what i mean but this but the
pizza has plenty of sauce look it's like
it's like eating the [ __ ]
it's like when you're having a nice
[ __ ] meal and you eat your broccoli
and vegetables first and you
you and you have like your chicken and
your steak afterwards you save the best
part of your life
you always eat everything separate not
always if
it like synergizes perfectly if it like
you would know i thought you would
[ __ ]
cross the house with the pizza no it
doesn't
the crust just takes the pizza tastes
like an italian hand on this piece like
it synergizes because when you get those
shitty frozen pizzas right that are like
one dollar or yeah right they're the
ones with no crust
you know those [ __ ] fake deep dish
pizzas that are just all bread yeah like
the thinnest
[ __ ] horrible that's like his [ __ ]
dream no my my [ __ ] dream
is like proper thin crust italian pizzas
where like
the the the pizza goes right up to the
crust and it's because it's so
thin it doesn't take it doesn't get in
the way
if it doesn't get in the way sorry you
got a grip on something
i don't give a [ __ ] about greasy [ __ ]
hands if the pizza tastes better
that's just optimizing the pizza there
is so much wasted space on pizza
that's it's it's like the crust gets in
the way of the pizza taste well then
okay why don't you do this then when you
get the pizza next time right and
there's a thick crust
just fold that [ __ ] in half oh yeah no
because that's like that's like
that means i feel like you're making a
problem out of this no no no no no no no
no
just roll up the pizza so that it's all
in one thing and then i
i just assume right whenever i see
anyone who you know leaves their crusts
on a sandwich
or you know leaves the crusts on a pizza
i'm like your parents clearly didn't
like
beat it into you yeah [ __ ] dude dude if
i if i left crosstalk
my mom would have beat myself she would
murder me she'd be like why are you
wasting food
i'll be like i got away with a lot of
[ __ ] but leaving food was not one of
them yeah no that's why that's why if i
have to eat pizza i eat it crust first
um like it's just
oh you make it sound like a [ __ ]
torture man it is torture for me because
you're ruining
you're ruining this good [ __ ] food
with just tasteless bread there's only
one time where it's acceptable to leave
the crusts on a pizza and that is a
buffet
of pizza where it's like i gotta
optimize this [ __ ] yeah i don't want
none of this because it's always [ __ ]
but if you just have dominoes then you
have to eat this yeah and
also and also in like crush just takes
extra room
it's just extra room in your stomach
that can be filled with nice
tasty pizza i don't want to get filled
up with like tasteless crust
i want always your [ __ ] [ __ ] pizza
okay
who is your stomach oh yes this tiny bit
of crust here is
i know i'm right i think i am not the
crazy one here
how do you like been quiet about this
for too
long crossless gang where are you at
where are you at crosslist guys
crosstalk
10 year olds raise their hand
[Applause]
point is where is the crush japan give
me i don't i don't like it they take it
for me because
sometimes i think the best part of the
sandwich is like the the give
that the cream adds to it right you
gotta bite it yeah yeah yeah target a
little bit
yeah sometimes it just crumbles apart
without the crust it's like the
integrity of this
sandwich has been ruined it's it's been
optimized it has not been
you you cut off all the useless pieces
although
i will say sometimes 7-eleven is the by
far the guiltiest of this
you'll get a sandwich from 7-eleven
right and they'll show you the sandwich
it looks like [ __ ]
packed in the front yeah yeah yeah this
thing is like quadruple ham slices right
you
you open up this sandwich thing you you
get it out you're like oh my god it's
thick and then as you realize you grab
it in your hand you're like huh
it's really really thin pretty thin near
the end you peel it up and there's
no ham yeah yeah yeah the other half of
the sandwich and you're like
i've been [ __ ] playing you got
[ __ ] click baited by seriously yeah
yeah
i think you have to like weirdly like
curl the bread up so you can get like an
even bite of bread it's [ __ ] 7-eleven
can you [ __ ] sort that [ __ ] out
everyone says their food is the best but
it's honestly the the worst one out of
the box i don't know family mart it's
okay
family master worse no i i have to stand
with family mart
oh my god no i'm i'm a i'm a 7-eleven
simp man
i i'm you're an awesome simp right yeah
i love lawson we look at the combination
we'll see
we're going to leave this for the
combini tournament arc okay we'll do it
we need to
ask there are three genders
oh my god no it's like the difference
between [ __ ] tesco's sainsbury's and
co-op right
you know yeah i don't know but i i'll
just agree with you
in that case but what do they have in
[ __ ] australia
what in terms of convenience stores yeah
um
yeah no one no one goes to a convenience
store in australia it's it's all just
supermarkets it's like
bottles as they say no that's a liquor
store yeah i know yeah
that is your lunch yeah i do i don't
want to buy food from a liquor store
i i will say probably the the thing that
i very quickly got adjusted to that i
think that will
hit me like whiplash when i return is uh
deliveries here
oh yes are you speaking of optimized you
get so used to it here because what
happens is
uh we spoke about this on the podcast
before we have i don't think so so when
you get a delivery in like i guess any
other country
it's like we'll arrive between 8 a.m and
6 p.m
and you just got to be home on a tuesday
hope you listen out
you know and then you [ __ ] miss it
and then they did a single note yeah and
they didn't knock on the door
they say that they were there and it's
like [ __ ] yeah yeah
um and then it's this whole [ __ ] pain
that you got to try and reschedule like
oh will you come back in
four days and it's like are you kidding
me i pre-ordered this game
i wanted it today but in japan
when you miss a package not only can you
reschedule on that day
within a two-hour time slot so if you
miss it between like 8 and 12 a.m
which is the only four-hour time slot
yeah you can get it re-deliver between
twelve and two
four and six six and eight nine ten same
day delivery literally the whole day and
you can pick the
two hours it's nuts and on amazon when
you do it you can also pick the two-hour
time slot it's
nuts yeah it's so insane and it works i
mean i mean there are also like what is
it where
the uk and stuff some places have like
in london have like amazon now
or something like that yeah that's
insane that's that that's insane
i think i spoke about that in the
podcast i ordered like mario party and
[ __ ] oh yeah
it's when it arrives literally a few
hours after you order it
man honestly i wouldn't be surprised if
japan gets it yeah yeah yeah i mean i
would love that
because i didn't know i would never
leave my house
well it was made for groceries
which is weird because i was thinking
back to our podcast last week
with uh with alexion and i remember
thinking to myself man
how would i have survived in japan and
got set up
if amazon didn't exist like like he did
like like when he first moved here and
i'm just thinking man so much of my life
has revolved around amazon
in japan that if i didn't have it i
would be like
life would be ten times harder it does
become when something isn't on amazon
i've noticed it becomes about 10 times
more difficult yeah
to get the thing that i want and
delivered because you have to look it up
and being like all right where's the
closest store and then you have to find
out when the stores open and then you
have to go in and [ __ ] look for it
it's just
yeah it's a mess gross but i also think
i also feel kind of sad because i feel
that
because everything is so easy
you know and i i i got comments that i
can't believe kind of complains about
not knowing japanese
and living in japan right not
complaining i'm just [ __ ] british and
i'm just complaining about the things
that i complain about i i know it's my
fault for not knowing jeffy he's
not a [ __ ] idiot i know that it's
probably not a good idea
to not speak japanese i think in japan
but a lot of people do come here to
learn yeah right and i do think that if
i was
forced to you know say 10 years ago or
15 years ago
i think that i would have been forced to
learn a lot more oh yeah because
i would have no choice all right right
right now i don't need to do anything
google maps tells you where to go google
maps tells me the restaurants
i can google translate every web page
yeah like it's pretty much all sort of
it's it's catering more towards
foreigners definitely
it also doesn't help that this is
basically a society that has optimized
like getting getting the least amount of
human interaction posture
you go to a restaurant you have a tablet
and you order your stuff you know you
so most of the time you don't even need
to talk to anyone you know what i mean
which is what i like i get you must get
this a lot right do you get comments
asking you like how's your japanese
coming along how's your japanese
kangaroo
yeah gone how is it coming it is
is it josu it is i've already gotten
josie a few times
it's difficult right because it's hard
to explain because essentially
i don't i think people have a
misconception of how much we interact
with japanese people
yeah i talk to a japanese person and i'm
forced to speak japanese
at like most often at the combini or
at the like denny's or whatever like at
a restaurant or a store
those are the three most common times
and there's a script like i know exactly
what they're going to say yeah yeah
because they always say i know exactly
what you mean because we were we were
getting coffee like i think it was last
week or something at the bookwork
offices and we
kind of ordered the coffee and he almost
sounded like [ __ ] fluent with
like all the responses he was making and
he was just and it was just like
i know how it is where you've ordered
something enough times that you just
know the questions
yeah i perfectly optimized ordering
coffee it's like when it's like when you
watch a movie and you say the line
before the action
i was like i know what you're going to
say and i know where
if that script is like buried like in
the slightest you just go
you just go like i have no idea what the
[ __ ] i'm doing what happens is i'll be
ordering coffee right and here's the
order every single time
you go in there you say what you want
they'll ask you do you want it to stay
or to go
yeah you say to go and then i'll ask you
you know do you want a bag
you say no you don't want to bag and
then you just say how you want to pay
so you can just say that right and it's
always how it is and every time it goes
wrong and if joey's with me i'll just
slowly turn to joey and be like
there's only two times i've seen a slow
head turn that's in a horror movie and
when i'm with you guys and you it's out
of the script
it's just a very slow length i don't
want to go yeah i don't want to go
joey help i just want to be like dozojo
i'll leave it it's it's it's actually
funny when you're not there because when
it's
something there have been times when
it's just me and connor and we're out
like a restaurant ordering something and
then we get we get something off script
and it's both of us trying to keep uh
like cumulatively
figure out which one of us knows like as
much japanese as each other like
like we're trying to like combine our
japanese knowledge to be like okay you
know this word i know that word
so we can let's try and figure out what
we're saying combining these two words
together
that's the thing though like that's like
one like i'm such a [ __ ] sadist but
like that's the one thing i [ __ ] love
when
friends who can't speak japanese i'm
hanging out [ __ ] and we go to like a
restaurant or something or we go out
somewhere or go traveling somewhere is
that
because i don't look japanese people
don't expect me to know japanese yeah so
i love every now and then going to a
restaurant with like a bunch of
non-japanese friends and pretending i
can't speak what a japanese
i just and just letting them be yes i'm
like
uh nihongo right and this is like
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you joy so yeah outside of you know
those situations i
we pretty much don't really speak to
japanese people although to be fair
you've been recently
[ __ ] interacting with like japanese
people on apex all right well so i i
thought to myself right
i'm taking these japanese classes two
times the problem is is i'm not really
doing much outside of that and
people will be like oh why don't you
study more i mean the work schedule that
we have is already pretty [ __ ] and
there's only so much studying before you
have to actually use it in practice
right i think like no matter how much
studying i do if i'm not using it yeah
yeah like practically it's not going to
happen yeah it's not poor so
i just decided [ __ ] it okay you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna stream
talking to japanese people on apex
trying to make friends yeah managed to
make some friends pretty [ __ ] fast
yeah
okay even though most people do not want
to talk i mean i was tuning in to one of
your streams and you were like
interacting quite
well i i can speak super super basic and
yeah but they were getting it
yeah yeah yeah they can normally
understand what i'm trying to say yeah
the best thing is is that if i don't
know something i'm like
chat chat what is this word how do i say
this thing and then they tell me and i
don't forget it yeah because i'm using
it like a meter yeah
over and over and so that's been really
helpful and if you want to go and watch
those you can watch them on the
highlights whatever they're doing
um but yeah that that's been super
helpful but outside of that like we
don't [ __ ] use it like i mean
you can you i i can talk to you guys and
jeff but it's okay joey it's different
because
it's it's different joey it's because
you know how bad we are and it's
embarrassing right no no okay okay you
gotta you have to throw that aside
because like i am fine doing it in front
of two thousand people live
yeah but not in front of me no not a
friend because
i'm not gonna judge you
we it's like a subconscious thing where
i'm just like
i don't want you to be disappointed in
me jerry
i'm not going to be disappointed i want
to just impress you man i want to
impress you okay
i just want to get any hunger you joseph
okay but i i know how jose your japanese
is man i i
can't i can't reach that level right now
man you're like trying to impress your
dad
come on man this is the only time i'm
gonna get my dad's love because
i don't know what it is about talking to
a japanese person i i even though it's
even more awkward because if they don't
understand me we're [ __ ]
yeah but it's less awkward because they
inherently expect me to be
[ __ ] awful yeah so it's it's like
when i do do good it's like oh awesome
like it's good so then why don't you
just put that on me because
you you can probably figure out what i'm
trying to say and you'll be like are you
trying to say this
but i can also just pretend to be like
i guess but it's
the point is in general we don't really
get to talk to as many japanese people
as
i think people expect us to yeah right
right right the sponsor of today's video
is
ej anime store cow's official online
anime merch store caters directly
towards overseas anime fans delivering
the newest and most exclusive merge of
all your favorite shows directly from
japan
did i just like hit the like 1.5 speed
on youtube or something
did you know many of the products are
only available
[Music]
look at all these awesome things you can
buy from pj anime store
yes yes many of their products are only
available for purchase during a limited
time reservation period so be sure to
check the pre-order deadline chat on
screen
i feel sorry for anyone watching at
times
yeah today's lineup first of all we have
the
harahi suzumiya woodblock prince i'm
very scared to touch this
oh my god very this is limited
quantities by the way limited numbers
and the there is a name for this i'm
gonna predict i'm gonna attempt to
pronounce like a welsh town yeah
i forget that japanese words don't have
spaces yeah exactly
celebrating the 15th and 10th
anniversary of its tv and theatrical
anime release respectively ej anime
still brings you this exclusive
commemorative ukioe woodblock
print which is only available through
reservation until december the 25th 2020
so get in quick
oh that's hot that's hot i genuinely
want that yeah like i'm honestly not
gonna lie i [ __ ] love hari
they also have the misfit of demon king
academy misha necron swimsuit version
i love swimsuit versions of this from
the aforementioned summer 2020
a tv anime series titled oh god oh you
want you want to try it
yeah you nailed it easy anime store
brings you a figure of the heroine misha
necron in a cute swimsuit
this special set includes this wall
scroll which uh you can now actually put
oh okay oh okay oh
oh okay very nice that's actually a very
nice feeling dude
yeah that's like the pillow you wish you
had like it was made like the hotel
pillow
yeah yeah
and don't forget the kuzakichan wants to
connor's breaking our items on camera
but the uzaki-chan wants to hang out
hanozaki lights nothing
light novel cafe asia version and this
one has the
extra culture in it you can tell look
look look at this
look at this look at the look at these
look at these the little detail right
here the little slit right there right
right they know what they're doing they
know what they're doing but we also have
the strike which is uh yoshika miya fuji
world witch's music festival 2019
version
as well which has one of the largest
[ __ ] backgrounds that i've ever seen
on the field so that is
that yeah your desk gonna be lot of
space on crying
shelf for this one but it looks neat i'm
going to pretend to have an opinion on
sprites rather than
strike witches never mind i don't know
what that is
i know what it is and i don't have an
opinion on it but you can get it through
ej anime store
be sure to go check these items out at
each animestore.com before they become
unavailable link available in
description below they have recently
been adding a variety of collectibles
such as body pillows and clothing to
their collection so be sure to stay
tuned for updates
back back to the video
that was you could understand everything
right yeah did you think you were gonna
talk more japanese like be forced to
when you moved here yeah
yeah i i i i i thought i did he said
there was such a remorse like because
it's so it's weird right because i think
everyone in my life expected me to as
did i
yeah but what ends up happening is that
i realized okay
i work from home uh i go to a language
school where all the staff speak english
all my friends speaking things yeah oh
no um
i stream i i speak in english i go to
the gym i don't talk because
who the [ __ ] am i going to talk to
unless that hulk guy talks to me yeah
i don't [ __ ] massive chat i've told
that story i think i have right
so yeah there's actually like pretty
much no time where
yeah i'm kind of the same as well like
right how often do you speak japanese
people outside of
business right um yeah i mean because
of covert i haven't been able to see my
family like at all right right yeah
and that as well has made it even worse
because strangers don't want to [ __ ]
talk to you
exactly i mean like our neighbor next to
us uh
is like really [ __ ] cool old couple
and like every time i see them like that
i'll talk to them in japanese but
i always get so nervous because the
moment i start talking to them
i can hear it in my inflection that like
oh no
i'm [ __ ] like losing touch on this
[ __ ] like i haven't been i haven't been
serviced yet
because i haven't been speaking enough
because all because the only time i'll
ever speak to is like with my mom
like an occasional skype call or [ __ ]
you know it's weird right you live in
japan
and you're like you're losing yeah yeah
so i have to you know i have to like
consciously
[ __ ] keep you know figuring out ways
of like okay
how can i use this language because if
there's one thing i don't want to lose
it's my japanese yeah of course yeah of
course and
here's the thing about languages is that
if you don't use it
it'll get rusty and that's true with
like mai tai as well yeah now that i'm
like out of shape yeah
now that i'm living out of thailand i'm
just like there's sometimes i'm trying
to remember entire word when i'm
speaking to my mom
and sometimes i get like the japanese
word instead because that's something
i've been like studying more recently
it's really yeah and it's it's weird to
think
how little i can have to how little i
can use japanese and also live here you
know what i mean because
you kind of subconsciously find a way to
make it easy for yourself not gonna lie
the one actually like one thing i have
been starting to do recently is like
every time i read manga or a novel a
japanese novel or something i read it
out loud
just because because if i read it in my
head like of course i'm going to
understand it no no no no no no no but
it's completely different like reading
and speaking skills is completely
different yeah
so i've like just kind of very quietly
read it to myself
just to be just to remember like okay
that's how you pronounce that word
yeah it's like that for me like reading
welsh it's like getting confusing now
because i haven't done it in a long time
yeah yeah and it's a
i mean you've seen that washed language
right it's a [ __ ] jumble of sounds
it's like all right
that's why i don't understand you know
people who know like [ __ ] eight
languages
some people just have it man yeah it's
just crazy right like
i don't think inherently i i would ever
learn more than one language because i'm
i'm lazy as [ __ ] i'll be honest yeah i
mean the thing is like to try to pick up
a third is like
[ __ ] my brain is like connor we're
really we're really going to a limit
here man
really pushing it but but i don't think
learning language is is
hard per se i think it's just like okay
if we just
all quit youtube tomorrow for like like
a year and just focus all our time on
actually learning this language
i think we'd make like so much progress
but
what's hard about it is trying to learn
a language and fit it within our already
current lifestyle where we're
busy as [ __ ] you know i mean i feel like
that's the real problem
because it's like i'm trying to find
time where time doesn't [ __ ] exist
nowadays
where like it takes a lot of [ __ ]
time and dedication to that
and it's a long line between being able
to speak a language
conversationally and being fluent in the
way
the only time i've actually gotten like
able to be and get get proper
japanese practice is when we're [ __ ]
out on the lash or something we're at a
random barns like
like we're we're [ __ ] pissed out of
our heads and that's just a random
japanese bloke who's as
pissed as us that's pretty much been
like the best language practice i've
gotten since i've moved here honestly
yeah that probably is the best way to do
it because
because you know if you're like a little
intoxicated then you're going to be less
you know nervous i swear to god i speak
i speak any languages like 10 better
when i'm drunk except english except
english
yeah it's so true [ __ ] man but i mean
like
languages from what i've learned is like
learning a language and learning music
or like an instrument is the exact same
part of the brain yeah
it's and they say like it's the exact
same with an instrument or language but
the second one is always going to be the
most difficult
and then from the third onwards it just
gets easier and easier and easier and
i guess for all for all three of us the
advantage is that we already know two
languages
quite formally so that's why and you
know you guys are learning a third right
so yeah it just puts pressure on me i'm
like
i should learn a third language as well
i mean it's weird because i don't feel
like i ever
learned two languages this is the first
time i've felt like i've
learned trying to actively learn
something where rather than just like
hey this is i just knew this as a kid
yeah
i didn't really think about it um
because you don't think about it in your
head when you speak time
because because the thing is it's just
like it is very much like learning and
learning an instrument it's just a lot
of it's like muscle memory
yeah yeah i do not remember how i
learned it i don't remember
learning it yeah i just know that i've
always been able to understand it and
speak it that's why i hate it when
people ask me like
japanese language questions i'm like i
don't [ __ ] know how yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it's also like when i and also
when you learn a language natively i
think you learn it wrong
you learn it locally and in a native way
yeah
people ask me some people would ask me
questions about welsh and i'd be like i
don't [ __ ] know
like i i just knew from speaking it yeah
i don't
i don't know any of the rules i i
couldn't do half of them correctly yeah
that's well that's why they say like the
best way to learn any language is to
live in the country that speaks it right
right right it's yeah i i don't know and
i i think i get a lot of questions about
like oh wait wait which language does
kind of speak well it's because like i
don't really get much
use out of welsh so i don't really show
it off right yeah unfortunately because
it's
only spoken in uh wales and
one part of like south africa south
america there's like one small
place in somewhere in south america
where they speak welsh like a town
really weird yeah a bunch of like walsh
atlas went there and we're like
[ __ ] it let's just make a list let's
chill here let's just do it
that's a shame because it's such a nice
language it sounds [ __ ] lovely
yeah yeah it's so cool it's always fun
hearing people pronounce the names of
the towns
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah isn't that that
buzzfeed video where i pronounce
like all the welsh names and it's
[ __ ] horrible they sound as cool as
they look as well oh yeah yeah because
like my
my dad can't speak welsh my mom could
speak welsh right so my dad
[ __ ] butchers that's the the names
and i always just correct him
yeah i just want to be an ass i'm like
oh yeah i do that to my dad with
japanese as well
i [ __ ] love doing yeah it's the same
situation yeah
it's like shut up son
going back to the whole like trying to
fit it around your lifestyle there is
such a big part of me that's like [ __ ]
man i wish i could take a gear off
youtube and like
do it like perfect a skill but i'd get
like just do japanese classes five years
ago
yeah i've i've like felt that definitely
recently where
like my entire life has just revolved
around youtube for like the past
four or five years and then i kind of
realized this last year especially
it was just like hey there are other
things i can do with my life
other than youtube and learning japanese
is definitely one of them but
i really only have time to you know do
one
without making like substantial progress
on the other or just like making
almost zero progress i mean this this
kind of situation definitely hasn't
helped considering that's really limited
where we can go right because i feel
travel as well even if you're traveling
with like a bunch of like
english-speaking people in japan
you just get into you can put yourself
into situations where you have to
interact with the locals right now yeah
you know just travel is such a nice way
of just meeting people and like getting
to use the language as much as possible
because like
i feel there's less stress using a
language you're trying to learn while
you're traveling because
at the end of the day yeah you're never
gonna meet this person again yeah i
would have no qualms about like
butchering japanese to an old lady and
yeah you get
[ __ ] nervous as [ __ ] trying to use
japanese at your local konbini right
because it's like i'm gonna see you
again probably tomorrow
same time oh my god and i don't want to
be remembered as that gaijin who can't
speak japanese
right as much as there's a party that
wants to do that i'm like at the same
time
i feel like i'm enjoying youtube now
more than ever oh yeah i'm enjoying
everything about it and
it's going so well that it would make no
sense to like
stop doing it yeah right like because
you know taking a year off youtube
although i could probably come back from
it i probably could but
is it worth the risk like no probably
not i can i can always learn japanese
later on in life which sucks that
i wouldn't have it now and i would
rather have it now yeah but
why not mix the two worlds together i i
i feel like i mean what do you mean by
that
like make some kind of youtube content
about you learning japanese i considered
that but i thought that'd be such a big
undertaking and i've seen language
channels and they had like drama
because they would like not end up
learning the language
no joke like they there was this video
where a guy made like an apology video
it was like technical drama
yeah yeah so like oh god cause you know
when those videos went around where it
was like
dude speaks 15 languages yeah yeah
you're like well that's just absurd
but then i i started watching a lot of
those videos and i found like
people who were like their whole channel
was about them starting from zero
and then learning the language yeah yeah
yeah and there was like drama with this
one guy
because he was learning two languages at
once right i think it was like i
remember it was like it was very
different languages as well
yeah and about halfway through like a
year in he's like you know what i'm
quitting i'm quitting swedish
you know i realized that it's just
hampering my progress trying to learn
two languages at once right
and all that it was like all the
comments were like what the [ __ ] man
i can't believe i believed in you like
your swedish was so good man why'd you
like and i was like oh my god anything
anything can be drama now and i just
thought like
i if anything it would be a thing where
i would be like okay
let's see how much i can learn in three
months doing x a week right yeah and
then i would not announce it not make it
a prop not make it a series just
yeah here we go yeah but at the same
time it also is a lot of pressure that
is like
okay i gotta worry about making other
videos and also actually learning
japanese yeah
otherwise this video is gonna be a
little awkward if it's like three months
in
i learned nothing but that would be
funny right
like it would be like a funny conclusion
to the video
so isn't it like i don't know i just
wasted three months of my life
and uh learned nothing he did it for
good content though you did 30 minutes
of your life watching this video exactly
i don't know
[ __ ] dude because i was because i had
this video idea where it's like because
i've always wanted to like
improve more of my japanese as well so
i'm like i can't just like
commit like outside of youtube or like
outside of what i do and all these side
projects i do because i'm just way too
busy
now which sucks because i really do want
to like you know hone in on my japanese
a lot more
so i thought about like you know there's
like the kanji proficiency test
yeah yeah and i've got like i got like
the third highest on that but like that
was back in like high school but i'm
like
i wonder if i can like go for the
highest one and
how many countries you need yeah for the
highest one uh i believe
it's three thousand and i think only
point
four percent of the population has it
yeah it's very like prestigious
yeah um but i thought like what if i did
a video where i
is there a kanji for cultural
cross-pollination i guarantee you there
is
a big one don't worry
but i thought to myself like i wonder if
i did a video where i just like
dedicated like a year
to just document myself like learning
that and trying to attempt for the test
but isn't that scary though because what
if you don't make
any progress like six months ago that's
the only thing that's stopped yeah
and it's also like in order for me in
order for this video to be successful
i've got to [ __ ] grind this [ __ ] yeah
yeah and
if i do this and then the video flops
then that's just like
cool i wasted a year of my life for a
flopped video and a test that i failed
i think unlike the actual japanese
language i think you actually can like
gamify and speed run kanji
like i think kanji is speedrunnable i
don't know man it is dude totally
playing
explain because you can there's there's
like
lit apps that will like [ __ ] whip you
if you get it wrong all right
so i i've speed learned like a hundred
kanji
in like a day by doing that and i know
all of them now i can use them but if i
sat you down and told you to write it
out could you
write it out some of them right but i'll
read them yeah but this i mean japanese
read them read them yeah you'll be able
to read 100 kanji if i showed you 100
really 100 percent okay
challenge except i'm tempted to do a
live stream we're both
and i'll [ __ ] do streaming kanji test
on you the basic kanji
the hundred countries you know i'll do a
test 100 we'll do it okay okay
okay because that's like a video idea
because right you can you can gamify it
like and and you can start picking up
patents and
i feel like the way that you can i don't
know like
at least when i was when i was learning
kanji i could easily pick up
kanji like i guess um because especially
living in japan right because
it wasn't like living in the uk sorry
where you learn this kind of g
you would leave your house you wouldn't
see it yeah you leave your house in
japan
even if you didn't talk to anyone you
see the kanjis everywhere yeah yeah so
you could keep practicing because you
keep seeing them like oh i know that oh
i know that
yeah you do do that after like every
like trash taste session yeah
we'll be catching the train you'll be
like what's that science say i've seen
that one before
yeah yeah yeah but i feel like that's
how that's the way you got to do it
right right right right because that's
that's how a kid learns yeah it's like
inquisitive yeah
problem is where it starts getting into
like there's four kanjis with four
different
the same country with like 10 different
pronunciations and it's like oh oh which
is like 30
of all kanji i love the ones with like
two i'm like nice
question of you boys uh because we've
been living here for a year now what's
the
how long you think you're gonna be
staying here for does that mean that's
the question i want to ask you too
what's what's what's my five-year plan
[Music]
was a [ __ ] liar chris board said he
wasn't gonna live here for like five
years and yeah and he's still here
i mean time just moves [ __ ] fast it
doesn't even feel like i've been here a
year
i i thought yeah i'll live here for like
two years max i'm halfway through i'm
just like i've hardly even spent
any time here right now i mean yeah
that's the thing like i i always thought
to myself i'm like
i thought about i was like oh my god
i've been for almost five years
like yeah like moved out like moved out
of my parents and like actually lived in
japan on my own i was like
it does not feel like five years which
is why like which is why like the
question of like
what do you see yourself doing in five
years it's starting to sound less and
less absurd to me
because back you know when i was in my
teenage years and people were like
where do you see yourself in five years
five years so far you'd be doing
something [ __ ] different every year
yeah back at that age
but now it just feels like it's you you
can have like a different
routine and monotonous now we just sound
old
i mean we are man we are depending on
how long well
a big [ __ ] question mark obviously is
you know
how long will geeks plus allow us to be
here because we
yeah mainly yeah melinda i i'm i'm not
calling you out right now
how long so i'm gonna i'm gonna say that
i'm gonna say this louder so
it all depends on how how long geeks
possibly around
because our visa depends on geeks plus
so
this wow this is why it takes so many
[ __ ] sponsors by the way yeah
we can give geeks plus money so that we
can satiate our [ __ ] like
lore overlords how many sponsors can we
fit ten an episode
say no more adorable doable man i mean
okay but but i mean like
like the question though i think and
this is kind of goes back to the root of
it all
having been here for a year are you guys
enjoying it yeah yeah there's been
i think i flip-flop a lot in the first
six months the first six months i was
like
i would have one week or i'm like i hate
it i plan to go back in two months
yeah you know what i mean like there's
some weeks where i think especially
where i've i said this in my video about
my because i made a video uh about one
year living in japan
yeah i think the big point i tried to
mention was like you have to make
like you have to force yourself to like
actively go out your way to make friends
here
yeah it is not a country where friends
just come along you don't just bump into
people and you're like
let's hang out it's like you actually
you have to go out of your way to do the
whole like
when are you free what's your calendar
like let's make the solid not a [ __ ]
thing let's do it otherwise
i'm not going to see anyone for two
weeks yeah you guys right yeah yeah and
like having this podcast has really
helped because
before it was like okay we might hang
out every day yeah but then we also
might not see each other for like a week
and a half yeah
and then i realized i haven't left the
house in four days [ __ ] i'm starting to
feel lonely and i live
i live alone and i've never lived like
alone alone like i've always
because we've always had a roommate i've
always had a roommate or something and
and i didn't realize like how much
i like relied on that to like kind of
keep me a little bit sane
yeah um because you know sometimes my
[ __ ] roommate uh
zeno i love you but yeah you drive me up
the wall right but that's not that's
also that's also not like
her fault it was like just a thing of
that that comes with just having a
roommate
eventually you just you live with
someone long enough you're like i
[ __ ] hate
just the little thing that you do and i
have no idea why yeah
and i thought i could live alone and
then i like one week into living alone
i'm like [ __ ] it's quiet in here
oh yes i was so [ __ ] depressed when i
started living alone here
right like before like you moved in with
me i was like [ __ ] man i've been out of
the house in two weeks i'm so [ __ ]
lonely right now
and like am i am i the only true
introvert here
i mean look i like my time alone don't
get me wrong right like i like my
timeline but there's only
so much time i like alone before i'm
like
i require the touch of a human oh no i'm
i i i'm the same because i remember
before i moved to japan i basically
lived alone for like
uh like three four months yeah um
because sydney was in america at the
time
and we were sorting out our visa stuff
for japan so there was just like
like a fair few month period where my
only social life would be when we'd be
able to like hang out in london
um and i don't know if it's just because
i've been in a relationship for like
four years
it was just like it was just it was just
like nice having
like just just living alone um and just
seeing
friends and seeing people when i wanted
to um because i guess the big difference
between japan and when i was living in
england is that
i could see someone whenever i wanted to
in england if i really wanted to yeah
you know what i mean
you could just message me let's hang out
yeah exactly exactly i feel like if
it was if it was the case of you know i
don't know when i'm going to see someone
next then i would be a way more lonely
um well that's why i'm like constantly
just like filling in plans like a head
up yeah yeah
like yo you want to hang out you want to
hang out you want to hang out late
otherwise
you're going to find yourself in this
kind of like dead space
of just no interaction whatsoever yeah
because like when i first moved here and
i didn't really have anything in my
house
and uh yeah i was just going on tinder
dates just because i was lonely yeah
yeah i didn't
like it sounds so sad but you know what
i didn't
do that man i mean and when i didn't
have you know anything to do i would
just
go to your your house but then i felt
bad you know because i didn't want to go
to their house every day and be like hey
i know you didn't mind but i also didn't
like i felt like i was intruding
right so and it was just sad you know
and it took me a while to get used to it
and getting used to being alone
that sounds so sad [ __ ] it
i mean living alone sorry yeah being
alone
i just have to get used to just being
you know in my soul
i figured how to have a healthy balance
of everything but it took me a while
because i did i wasn't used to it right
i always had someone in my house that i
could always be like yo you want to
watch tv you know
so is this your subtle way of asking us
to come to your house
please no no no so like okay so we're
going back to our
like original [ __ ] topic of this
video of like online friends and
everything
when did you guys realize that online
friends just wasn't
enough he couldn't feel that whole that
having real
physical friends that you can see like
like
after i had like a really healthy friend
group i think like
irl friend group yeah yeah after you
have like an actually good irl friend
group that like you just
you would rather hang out with more than
like anyone um yeah i feel like there's
no going back
yeah yeah i i feel that as well because
i found my i found like my first proper
true friend group
like at the age of like 23 24 that's
when it kind of started
and i remember like my mom had like
[ __ ] up my entire perception
because my mom had raised me for like
18 years to be like don't give a [ __ ]
about your high school friends
your real friends for life your actual
real friends will come in university
so i go to i go to university and i just
i'm just there with my like my
housemates my coursemates i'm just
looking around i'm just like
i hate everyone around me i feel like
mike wazowski's
like where are the friends yeah it's
just like where are the friends
mum why would you lie to me mum why
would you lie to me
so yeah i'm i'm not in contact with like
anyone from like in my university days
like some more so in my high school days
where university was
university was just like a [ __ ]
cesspool right
where i was definitely i definitely have
more in contact with my high school
friends than i do my uni friends
yeah like not say i don't have any uni
friends like i have you know some of my
uni friends are [ __ ] best friends
forever but
yeah yeah i don't know like i think that
whole thing of like oh don't worry about
high school because there won't be a
friends for like
i think that's kind of [ __ ] yeah i
think you'll you'll know if you've made
a friend for life yeah yeah yeah exactly
so i think it's like
there is no designated time when you
will make friends for life
it will happen along the way but i
remember like
finding my first friend group and now i
was just realizing oh
so i don't have to pretend to be someone
likeable to be around you guys because
you just
you guys just kind of like me for the
person i am yeah and that was just like
so mind-blowing for me what the [ __ ] is
that all about
yeah cause it's just like having friends
that are like just like you know even
though there's like a lot of
a lot of people it's just like
everyone's there to help each other like
if you're having a low point
it's the whole philosophy of god you're
a [ __ ] but i love you yeah you know
it's that yeah you know and just like
mates they're just there for you like
regardless of like you know what's going
on yeah and i i really really really
value that
yeah and uh it's a shame as well because
i'm i [ __ ] hate texting
so much i absolutely despise texting
yeah same here
and i pretty much the only people i text
are like people i know
that i'm going to meet up with that i'm
like yo when we meet or not what's
happening you know like oh it's like
business or anything but outside of that
i avoid like the plague
because i just hate it why do you hate
it i just it doesn't feel genuine and it
takes so long
it's i'm like i'd rather have a 30
minute call than text for like a whole
day back and forth
all right yeah yeah same here like i'm i
mean i'm sure you both know i'm [ __ ]
all for replying to oh god
it's worse bro and that's because like i
it takes for me it takes like so much
mental energy to like
be i get it i can look at notifications
that i just i just have to like
have a dedicated time when i check
messages otherwise one i just get
distracted from whatever i'm doing
and i i much rather i i value so much
having like a just
an in person or like an invoice like
actual communication because
there's so much that i can't communicate
when it's just during text that i just
i just rather talk to people i don't
know i feel like i get that
i feel like a lot of you know a lot of
context is
almost lost as well when you're just
texting as well yeah like a lot it can't
be
like all the emotions can't be like you
know portrayed properly yes
um yeah and you know i kind of realized
as well that the
the friends you'll have in life the ones
that like i might not text right now
yeah like the real friends are the ones
where it doesn't matter i don't [ __ ]
need to text them
yeah like even for a year or two i i i
go back and then it's exactly yeah it's
exactly the same
it's exactly the same the way i see is
like it's kind of like a family reunion
yeah yeah i mean and i didn't i didn't
fully understand
the term where i was just like friends
of the family you choose
until i had a proper friend group yeah i
was just like i i remember hearing that
for like my entire life and thinking
that's such a [ __ ] term
that's like this like cheesy disney
movie
that isn't actually real it's a [ __ ]
urban myth it's a [ __ ] urban legend
you know yeah
it wasn't the destination it was the
friends we made along the way
so with that being said yeah back to the
the question at hand which was
how are you going to stay in japan what
do you think what do you think boys
because i think
right now my main con thing is that like
at the end of the day
with all my gripes that i had and i i've
made them very known as the comments
like to point out that they think i
despise japan i'm very critical of
everything in life yeah
and uh at the end of the day japan the
standard of living is just much higher
at the moment
especially especially when you're
british you just learn to complain about
all the little yeah yeah a lot of people
just think that i i really see a lot of
comments like connor's so [ __ ] rude
about japan i'm like no i'm just pretty
it's just being real bro it's just
people just being brilliant
we complain about everything yeah okay
here's a question to you guys
so we all are living in the place that
is not where we were born
did you always know that you would move
out of your home country and live
somewhere else
yeah absolutely i like cause like at
least for me
i moved out of the house that i was born
in
yeah so i never moved until i moved out
of my home so
i've been living in that like my parents
house for like 21
years straight and i was just like yeah
it's home but yeah it's also like
you know you go home and you just see
the same view out of the window every
day right
yeah i need i need i need something else
i i love my home don't get me wrong yeah
but
i think especially because i was so
active online from such a young age yeah
yeah i became so aware
like globally of other different places
right and then it just made me curious
yeah yes
i i remember yeah going back to my
[ __ ] mum
it was just i remember like when i was a
kid i was just like mom
i'm i'm telling you this now love
england's but i'm going to move out
three-year-old
i was like you know between like when i
was like going from a kid to a teenager
i
[ __ ] knew that i would like move out
of england eventually and i was like mom
don't take this personally i'm just
gonna move out i'm gonna i'm not gonna
be in the country my mum was like
sure sure bets
okay son whatever you say and i remember
when i told her hey mom i'm just gonna
like [ __ ] move to thailand for a few
years she was like surprise pikachu face
like
like nanny you you are actually serious
all these years and yeah because
like not that i don't love england but i
one i wanted to
experience like different cultures and
everything since i was a [ __ ] kid
and two like i i don't know it's
i was always in my head i was always
thinking that there was this perfect
place to live
that wasn't the place yet that you were
from because everywhere else seemed so
exotic right
and everything and like the more i move
around the less idea i have about where
i
truly want to [ __ ] settle down it's
it's really weird right because you
especially if you live like stay in the
place for like any substantial amount of
time
you see all the great things that that
are there and you also see the bad
things there's no [ __ ] perfect place
and the more the more you move around
the more you realize there is no perfect
place so
yeah you got to make that decision of
hey where what is what is actually best
for me you know
legit when between the ages of like 12
and 16 i thought america was the perfect
place
i thought america was i really i really
wanted to live in america yeah
all my life until like age and probably
actually until like i moved to japan i
still like before that i was like i kind
of still want to go to america man
i don't know always since young age i'd
always been exposed to american culture
i always spoke with americans online
yeah and i just really loved their style
of doing things
yes i love how [ __ ] crazy they are i
don't know i think i i think it's
because for me it's like i didn't really
like interact with any americans
i think that's the thing right because
like literally from age 12 i've been
chatting with people online always voice
chatting like my parents
for some reason didn't stop me and most
people
and most of the online friends you got
were just from america right yeah
yeah a lot of a lot of the people you
were friends with were from america i
was the token british friend most of the
time they were like it's [ __ ] corner
no we weren't cool back then yeah we
were that was when we were respected
online yeah
god i miss those days now it's all
[ __ ] memes and bad teeth and tuesday
youtube youtube in it this video is
sponsored by
mac weldon when it comes to holiday
gifting for guys i'll admit it's not
necessarily my strong suit but that's
where mac weldon comes in now thanks to
mack weldon it's super easy and simple
to find something great no matter which
guy you're shopping for whether you're
shopping for yourself
or for the boys hell yeah the boys is
all that matters
you can get everything from mac weldons
men's essentials
socks shirts hoodies underwears
polos and active shorts
hey i have the active shorts guys don't
clown do you do you have the acting
phone i actually do
i wear them to the gym mac weldon has
men's basics that are guaranteed to keep
everyone on your list comfortable like
this sweller
that i wear when i'm feeling lazy at
home thank you mac weldon
and this t-shirt which just look look at
how breathable this t-shirt is look look
at it perfect for the gym which is where
i wear it to when i go to the gym
once a year apparently and joey's mask
and my mask which i'll wear
everywhere to keep myself safe that's
why mac walden makes the perfect gift i
also have the sunday lounge pants at
home which i didn't bring with me
uh because there's stains and [ __ ] all
over them because i don't leave the
house when i wear them because they're
so damn comfortable
i just can't get out of the house but
they also look pretty stylish too
mac walden looks great and feels great
from working out
going out going to work or on a date mac
walden is for everyday life and all mac
world and stuff comes in a wide range of
customized fabric that keeps up
with you no matter what your day looks
like 18 hour silver r
and it's dryness warming too many
goddamn nits that's for sure plus you
can check out weldon blue which is their
totally free loyalty program level one
gets you free shipping for
life and once you reach level two by
spending two hundred dollars
you get twenty percent off every order
for the next
365 days but boys you can't forget about
the mac weldon guaranteed
mac weldon wants you to be comfortable
so if you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can keep them and they'll
still refund you
no questions asked that is very generous
it very much
i would have thought mac walden would
have one wanted me to send back the
underwear but no
they they're just like they're just like
no bro keep it they can they can only
imagine the heinous [ __ ] you've done in
those after watching the hentai episode
of trash taste
but win the gift-giving season and get
20 percent off your
first order visit macweldon.com trash
taste and enter promo code trash taste
that's macweldon.com trash taste and use
the promo code
trash taste for 20 off mack weldon
reinventing men's basics i [ __ ]
nailed it thank you to matt walden for
sponsoring this episode back to the
video yeah the more i think about the
more is kind of [ __ ] weird that i did
speak to like
just anyone like online i would never
let my kid do that
i would never let my kid do that i don't
know why i did it your parents are just
cool with it
were your parents aware of it no i
didn't tell them
yeah i would just tell them that i was
talking to my friend they're like who
are you
because okay so when i used to swear
right like so i lived
i lived my room was upstairs right so
whenever i swore too loud and my parents
heard it i
i would hear this at the stairs i'm like
stop swearing because my dad swore a
bunch right but he you know he tried not
to around me but i [ __ ] i was
i could not stop swearing yeah because
you're that one angry kid on xbox
because right if you wanted any cred as
a 13 year old you had to curse
man come on you got to talk [ __ ] i mean
i don't i can't relate
did you did you have you ever given any
13 year old kid cred now that you're in
the
the opposite end yeah if they shout yeah
but when you're third okay be fair okay
british xbox is a different beast
whatever the [ __ ] you had dude it was
because everyone in these lobbies was
like 13
14 15. that sounds like this that sounds
like every xbox worldwide
the [ __ ] game more cause i was
[ __ ] screaming at someone then
for some reason you were legit that one
squeaker i know
i i wasn't i was okay was i squeaking
then maybe i was squeaking yeah
who knows right you were you were a cod
squeaker yeah god
oh my god c dog va confirmed called
squeaker
oh my god that was so funny yeah so many
dumb so much dumb [ __ ] i did on xbox
yeah yeah
oh my god so here's the question now
then now that we've now that you've like
gone to japan and gone to america and
these are like the two place you really
like kind of like
fantasize about yeah when you were
younger is there any place in the world
that you still want to go to or is it or
is it or just like yeah what's what's on
everyone's like country
or is it all just downhill from here
like i've been everywhere i want to
there's nowhere else i want to go
okay not
really here's the thing right because
people people like
say oh i want to go here over here like
there's some countries people like i
really want to go here i'm like why
why the [ __ ] would you want to go there
yeah they're like like what i'm looking
at
i'm not going to know any examples this
is going to sound [ __ ] terrible right
there are some countries right where
it's like
not going to lie if i want a vacation
somewhere i want to know that i can [ __ ]
in a clean toilet
okay i'm just going to say right is that
a bad thing am i allowed to say that
that's a very privileged thing that's
hella privileged i know it is but at the
end of the day i'm just going to be
honest i don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the hole in the ground man it's
okay so much you never get used to it no
yeah
have you have you ever had to use the
hole in the ground
[ __ ] yeah france i had to and i thought
i thought this was a [ __ ] civilized
country what is this
i don't know okay this is like i used to
go camping so much so like sitting in a
hole was just normal for me because
right
oh i i spoke to alan uh yeah and and
sure when he comes on the podcast you
can tell about it yeah
tell us stories about how his dad forced
him to go to kenya on holiday oh yeah
yeah
and he made his sound out like it was
[ __ ] hell and i'm like
why the [ __ ] would i want to go on
vacation there
when everything sounds horrible like
what
like if i vacation all i want to do is
just relax and just chill out yeah
i don't want to [ __ ] do activities i
don't want to [ __ ] write it like i
don't want to [ __ ] be uncomfortable
everyone everyone has my granddad
honestly i'm i'm already accepted that i
am
like a 60 year old white dude when it
comes to like you just don't want to
like advice
in another country right i don't either
i'm 100 with connor in this i'm fine
with doing an activity on a day or two
you know
again okay maybe we can hide but i do
not want to [ __ ] do [ __ ] every day
i also don't want to have to like i
don't want to have pressure
that i need to go see something yes if
i'm in a place and i'm just like you
need to go here you need to go there you
need to see this i'm just like i hate it
already
like i i will go i will go to one cool
place and i'm and
it's just like i've seen enough i'm
satisfied can i just go home and just
like
[ __ ] enjoy a pine or something that
that's that's my that's my perfect
holiday and it doesn't come from a place
maybe it does come from a place of
privilege i don't [ __ ] yeah it probably
does but
i honestly don't give a [ __ ] i just want
to chill on my heart
i think it's just cause of like what i
went through as a kid because when when
you go on holiday as a kid right
you got to follow what everyone else is
right and you i always had i always like
had this [ __ ] especially
if i go into like a big group like the
stacked [ __ ] itinerary
well all i wanted to do was just stay in
my [ __ ] hotel room and playing my
nintendo ds
that's all i wanted to [ __ ] do on
holidays dude because we used to i used
to go camping uh for
uh in france like i said every year for
three weeks right
and i in most years i [ __ ] hated it
yeah and my parents thought that i was
just like
they thought it you know okay i get it
now what they think they're like oh he's
just saying he hates it yeah you know
what i mean like
he's just that's a knitter no no i
actually hated it like
it was like you were in a tent you were
sleeping on the floor it was
uncomfortable so it's like three weeks
you're eating the same [ __ ] like
everything okay so everything is grilled
on a barbecue i love i love
camping don't get me wrong i used like
my dad used to take me camping like in
the [ __ ] australian outback like
all the time but it wasn't for three
weeks it was like tops like five days
that's the thing right i think three
weeks is way too i think that's what
like has completely put me off
vacationing in any places that aren't
just like
honestly just like relaxing in a nice
bed yeah just
eating nice food like that kind of like
put me off for life because i spent
most of my childhood summers just
sleeping on the floor
eating everything that had to be grilled
yeah because that's all you had to cook
right it was a grill baguettes non-stop
and then always always those horrible
public showers that are never clean
and then sometimes you would see like
piss in the corner and it would always
smell and it was just awful
like everything was awful and even as a
12 year old i could be like
i'm is this some peasant joke i'm too
rich to understand right like i i just i
don't know like i
i really like that that would throw me
off i would always be like at home we
had a toilet
that was nice and it didn't stink of
just everything
why does it here i i also wonder how
different my perceptions of a lot of
these activities would be
if i actually went nowadays
with my mates because three weeks like
yeah yeah part of part of the reason i
like look back and dread about it is
because you spent it with you were
forced to be there
with like your family and something you
wanted to do something else
that your family didn't want to do and i
feel like that's just like
that that kind of memory has been
ingrained into me that i just like
i hate this activity because i did that
[ __ ] as a kid and i hated it yeah
because my parents were obsessed with
like
maximizing the [ __ ] out of the day like
i was like yeah
let's let's go if we go in france it's
like yeah let's just walk around this
town all day and i'm like [ __ ]
no i want to go to the arcade all day
i don't i do not want to walk all day
like i'm starting the age where walking
just hurts
all day right i don't know like for some
reason when you're when you're a kid
like walking long distances just doesn't
work like
were you an active kid 100 like yeah i
was doing sports two three times a week
oh okay
but for some reason just walking when i
had to walk all day
it was just pain which is pain man
and then when you're a kid right there's
nothing more boring than
fishing and i would have to do it that's
true and i thought i'm glad my dad
never got me into fishing like my dad
[ __ ] destroyed something that i could
see me enjoying now
with a mate and drinking a friend
i've actually been fishing for the first
time recently which is like two years
ago with uh
sydney's dad and sydney's uh brother
took me fishing for the first time
i actually really [ __ ] enjoyed it
right right as an adult it's one of
those things that like as a kid
you're just not wired yeah okay okay
they're they're it's gonna make me sound
so bad but there is one big difference
about why i can enjoy it now versus what
i could enjoy as a kid
and that's because alcohol is now on
yeah yeah yeah
i have never seen a man fish with not a
beer in that little pocket yeah
yeah yeah it just doesn't happen because
i mean it's not part of the charm yeah
right like
going it as a kid it is just like it's
the adhd simulator because
all you want to do is like why is there
enough fish catching on this immediately
yeah oh
i'm trying to get this [ __ ] thing on
the thing on my [ __ ]
yeah where's my nintendo ds i need to
[ __ ] cook your mama for 20 minutes
relax
you're trying to do it and nothing
happens you get [ __ ] fish and as a kid
you're like let's let's kill it and eat
it let's let's do something yeah let's
do
let's [ __ ] [ __ ] decapitate this
fish and then that your dad's like we
throw it back here
what's the point i want to eat it you
know
because you're a kid and you think in
every video game i've caught it and i've
eat it yeah why are you stopping me down
it's the worst activity for a kid
yeah it's it doesn't make sense and just
the whole thing
just completely ruined like doing that
kind of stuff for me as an adult now
because i have
no interest yeah yeah i i would actually
go back fishing with my mates because
it was just like a nice mail we should
go fishing we should [ __ ]
go fishing with you i haven't been
fishing for like five years
i will tell you what because i've had
this image of what fishing would be like
my entire life
and because like my only my only
experience with fishing
my entire life has been through the
[ __ ] fishing mini games you get in
every [ __ ] every [ __ ] zelda game
or every like it's in animal crossing
whatever
play for the free controller yeah yeah
yeah exactly and i thought to myself
there's no way it's going to be like
this and i was [ __ ] surprised at how
accurate that simulation is
like it literally felt like a controller
rumble and i'm just like
oh like this is just like the [ __ ]
video
it's like where's the a button yeah yeah
yeah it's it's literally just instead of
tapping the a button you just go
shhh and yeah it's but for some reason
it was just like it was like very
therapeutic
and uh if you like fishing fishing mini
games it's exactly like that and i was
surprised
every like fishing enthusiast is just
like frothing at the bathroom like how
[ __ ] dare he say that
man yeah i don't know man i just it's
completely like
so to answer your question joey oh god
sorry uh no
i mean there's not really any other
countries that i'm like desperate to go
obviously i want to i still
have never been to any of asia so i
really want to explore asia yeah
like there's so many activities that i
like the idea of you know like like i
like the idea of camping
you know i mean the idea two two days
it's charming
the idea sounds cool until you [ __ ]
wake up and it's like
the the [ __ ] worst thing i hate is
when you wake up and everything's just
damp you feel things and it's just damp
and damp is like
the worst [ __ ] climate you know what
i mean it's it's like
everything's damp and moist and i'm
depressed and it's cloudy and i'm just
like why am i here
i chose to be here this is supposed to
be relaxing i don't think you should
come camping in australia man it's like
it's like [ __ ] dry yeah but then
everyone everything wants to [ __ ]
kill you and i have something else to
worry about
only if you go out and [ __ ] with the
animals don't [ __ ] with the animals and
they'll leave you alone because camping
in the uk is just
either [ __ ] cold [ __ ] or just not
gonna lie i can't believe the uk sounds
[ __ ] horrible
like i mean because we have to do a
thing in the uk called like oh you don't
have to do it it's optional duke of
edinburgh did you do that
my sister did that yeah well you
basically like have to do a bunch of
things to get a
a [ __ ] like go out camping yeah yeah
yeah yeah and
they always told you in school it's like
you should get it because it's going to
look amazing when you apply for jobs and
no no no one can't say that no one cares
and on it like yeah you have to do like
a hiking slash camping thing where you
uh do two days of like full hiking with
like the big bags
yeah and then camp and i this this could
only sound like so [ __ ]
stupid but i was the only one who was
like i'm ringing a pillar
i want to be comfortable when i sleep
the privileged white boy
yeah i don't know so i i big brained it
right because all these kids brought
like dumb [ __ ] right and and we had to
we
brought like a stove to cook on as well
yeah like 16 as well so
i brought the pillow right and as i was
sleeping they all started [ __ ] trying
to take it from me
because i cuz they were sleeping on the
hard floor rolled up and i'm like no no
no i'm the one who was the stupid dick
who carried this pillow all the way for
like eight hours
this is my pillow this is my reward and
i woke up and one of them had [ __ ]
took it and i woke up
on the thing covered in [ __ ] dampness
and i was like oh my god
did it rain bear in mind this is the
three person ten four of us in it
and i woke up being like oh my god it
must have rained so much i go outside
it's completely dry right and i'm like
oh it was sweat
it was all sweat it was all condensation
ah
yeah because my sister didn't duke of
edinburgh but she did like the highest
level so she like hyped where it's like
it's like a week right yeah she hiked
across vietnam twice
what yeah yeah why would you why would
you want to do that i don't know i did
it twice though
i did two days and i was like i think no
this isn't for me i
i i'm going to go back to sitting on the
bed and watching
me i think that
this isn't for me why why did you even
like decide to do it
well because it's one of those things
where it's like i can do it
yeah if you asked me to go hiking for a
week i'll do it i'm very capable of
doing it right yeah i just hate every
second of it well why do you accept it
my parents were like you should do it
and i was like fine okay okay
and i was doing the other stuff anyway
because i was i was teaching kids chess
at my old school yeah uh i don't know
man like i knew from the get-go when
like the
the option was brought up off would you
like to do duke of edinburgh like would
you like to go hiking
and [ __ ] experience dampness for a
week straight i was like yeah
of course i don't i think because as
well they wanted like the kids who had a
lot of experience
camping to help the kids who hadn't done
any
and it was only like there was only like
three or four boys and like the boy
scouts
in like my year and then there was like
me who done a lot of camping
so it was like okay so you were the
experience i guess yeah to me it was
like connor should help out and you're
the boy scout
you know i never did anything like map
direction or anything like that
my parents [ __ ] did all that i might
barely help with setting up the tents
yeah
like you just put the bag down yeah i
used to be like i'm going to play with
the frisbee
so when we did it i do remember this as
well like when it came i was like i'll
i'll do the cooking you could you can
set up the 10 because
and because it was one of the cheap ones
as well and the cheap ones are like
connect the 576 poles together and it's
like no
none of them can get it right and i'm
like i'm gonna cook the bacon that i
brought
yeah i was yeah i i i i've been down to
go camping though in japan i've never
been camping in japan
we should do glamping yeah camping is
cool i've never gone i've never it's
like camping without all the
frustrations it's like camping with
privilege it's like coupling with
civilization like if we didn't if we
didn't want to like
invent all this [ __ ] we wouldn't happen
yeah that might be real i don't want to
camp without 4g
like what's the point i'm just going to
say it right i know it's not the same i
don't give a [ __ ] i want 4g
i can count without 4g i can cancel this
okay you know you know what you know
what i need a toilet you're right
toilets yeah i i i don't want a [ __ ] in
a [ __ ] bag or a hole in the ground
with there's a reason there's a reason
[ __ ] humans evolved
and invented toilets in civilization
have you ever wiped your ass with a leaf
no it just doesn't work but that's all
you have
what are you gonna do grab a handful of
grass no you have to use leaves and hope
you can just get most of it out it's
awful well that's why like the one thing
we always took camping was a
like a bunch of toilet rolls damn dude
20 20 man yeah
yeah because what you just you go out
into the bush you'd wipe yourself i'll
put it in a bag and then you throw all
of that
i must have been as like 12 year old me
it was like instant noodles or toilet
rolls
chicken flavor or poopy butt like oh god
it was i do remember when we did it
there was awful because like there was a
lot of kids that were
just not prepared at all yeah and had
never even done any hiking at all
right and those those things are heavy
yeah yeah and a lot of them just
couldn't do it and you had to stay as a
team
so it's like every 15 minutes one kid
would have a [ __ ] mental breakdown
yeah and it was like i can't do it i
so the only thing that like puts me off
camping in japan from what i've seen
like only only like the pictures and
everything i've seen is that it looks
very
how can i say it's commercialized
because it's it's like you have this
like camping sport and like i see a
bunch of tents there
it's very privileged yeah yeah and i'm
just like you're put right next to
someone
yeah yeah and it's just i remember the
one thing
um i remember about camping is just like
how
little noise protection you have from
one intent to another right
you hear everything yeah right and
especially
the what i you know especially the
camping experience i would like to have
which is like a bonding mate sesh like i
don't know
especially if you have like a bunch of
japanese people around you with tens and
everyone values their privacy can you
imagine how quiet you'd have to be
oh we could just be those like ignorant
gaijin just be like
you know if no one's making noise at
this campsite i think we will like [ __ ]
it
what are they gonna say you just hit
like 2 a.m just like aggressive uno
noises
like from drunk people
i don't know [ __ ] jojo uno session at
two in the morning in a tent
should do trash taste hiking special oh
i'd be down man i used to go hiking all
the [ __ ] time actually that's that's
the idea what the other worst part is
it's actually not a bad idea yeah yeah
i'd be down there i'd be down
you know it's it's all about i'd be
willing to do it now is it for content
okay i'm willing to [ __ ] suffer for
content whatever i am
i am i am that's that's that's the
tipping point right at least like
i'll do it but is it monetized
yeah all right i'll do it how do we get
on talking about camping
i don't know but like uh yeah so yeah
what the [ __ ] we were talking about oh
yeah if you're going to stay in japan or
not
oh well i mean oh no no no it was it was
like which country would you visit
because like is there a country that's
at the top of your bucket list right now
for like visiting
korea korea korea korea yeah i really
want to go to south korea for me it's
iceland
iceland yeah yeah i don't know i love
everything about that country the
language the
just the culture around i'm like all the
places i've seen
because it's such a tiny country right
so it's like if you have a car
you could [ __ ] and you have a week
you can probably visit most of that
country i do want to go mexico but a lot
of people i know who are mexican who are
like uh yeah it's dangerous as far as
yeah yeah
what i've heard i'm like oh okay yeah i
really like how safe it is here
exactly exactly like it's like it's like
food's amazing
really good time yeah it's really
[ __ ] dangerous yeah yeah exactly
is there one for you do you have like a
[ __ ] list of like yeah i've only got
this
i mean probably iceland is at the top i
i do want to really go back to korea as
well
yeah career i i've only been enough like
a few days but i feel like that just
wasn't enough time for me
yeah i'd love to go yeah it's
highlighted it's just the stones are
away right like
i really want to go to thailand as well
oh yeah i definitely want to go to
southeast asia more yeah yeah i want to
i want to go to vietnam as well you've
never been to singapore either or
malaysia or
any i've never been anywhere in asia
except for japan yeah so i really want
to
see like i i want to travel more around
asia because i feel like there's
only a few asian countries that i
haven't visited 2020 psych
yeah trash taste south asian tour
like i mean i i do want to visit just
everywhere really and just make my own
you know i i i joke and say i just that
i don't want to go to a lot of places
but
i wouldn't mind going and passing
through and checking it out you know
like egypt i really want to go to
nigeria um australia i really want to go
to australia south africa i really want
to go to
yeah um you know and i i was joking
about kenya but i you know
i'm sure i could have a nice time there
and i'm just being ignorant as [ __ ] i
really wanna show there's gonna be
comments saying that i am oh yeah of
course
because like i've i've always thought
like i don't really want to like visit
like
this place like africa for instance or
like you know the middle east and stuff
like that but like the more i kind of
hear about those places
from people who are either from there or
just from [ __ ] you see it's just like
yeah you know what that actually might
be kind of dope
i don't know but it's just it's such a
toss up though because there there's a
lot of those countries we just hear
nothing about yeah right and you're just
like is it
are we hearing nothing about it because
it's it's bad or
because people just don't go australia's
like a country you don't hear much about
but it's pretty nice i really like
austria yeah right
just super chill you go skiing there
right yeah i've been skiing in austria
um and snowballing in there and italy
mm-hmm
it's really nice just skiing in europe
or snowboarding in europe in general
it's like
it's super expensive but yeah i really
really want to do it it's really nice
yeah i really i just want to go to
europe mall
yeah everything's just super [ __ ]
expensive this is just like a travel
wishlist now
this is just us fantasizing and covered
times yeah i'm just kidding remember
remember before covert existed and we
could travel to places
yeah i do want to go back home and visit
my family because it's weird because
this will be like the second
christmas in a row where i haven't seen
them which is normally would be the
thing where it's like okay i'll go back
for christmas
yeah you know um but yeah i mean that's
that's one big thing but as far as
living in japan goes and i mentioned on
like you know the quality of life being
really good here
i definitely felt like at least another
two years i want to stay here yeah and i
think it'll be a case of
in a year i'll know if it's going to be
another two years it's one of those
things where i i'll just as it goes i'll
keep changing that number
that's how it is like from like with a
lot of my friends who are from overseas
who live here or have been living here
it's always the case of you know
all right we'll give ourselves one more
year see how it goes and then usually
like 90 of the time after that year ends
up it's like
another year and then it just keeps
going right and it's such a pain to move
[ __ ] back it's like
it's worth the like i really can't be
bothered with that again but
do you guys feel this as well i don't
know if you guys feel the same but like
for me this has been the first year
where
what i do actually feels like a career
as opposed to just me just being
self-employed doing my own [ __ ] job
that
you know i mean i've never been employed
yeah yeah yeah yeah once all this point
sorry
it just feels good it just feels like
for for the first time this isn't just
a job it's like my career now yeah and
um i don't know just you
you you don't think doing like doing
like youtube and your job that
environment really
matters because you can do technically
do it anywhere but the more like i've
done this and the more i've
growing up the more i realized hey
environment really [ __ ] matters in
in your works oh yeah like i remember
going like i remember in university
where i'm just like i can do youtube
wherever
i can do in my in my [ __ ] room you
know i can do it next to my bed
and then i slowly realize i need my own
[ __ ] office i need my own [ __ ]
space
i i i need to separate you know work
and my leisure time because you can you
can like you can survive with it and you
can do it but
you're just there there'll end up be a
point where you get
[ __ ] depressed and you get tired and
you just it's not healthy
you know yeah yeah i mean it definitely
completely changed my
productivity but also just like my
enthusiasm towards my
career and i guess like it really
cemented the severity
of what i do of like this isn't just
like a little fun thing that you get
paid for like this
this is this is your job right now this
is your career like
putting food on the table is this now
and everything you do
revolves around this and definitely you
know
like moving to a bigger place and
getting my own like actual work room has
like really cemented that like okay
yeah this is like yeah i can [ __ ] around
on camera and be silly and goofy
yeah but it's also my job like i can't i
can't half-ass this [ __ ] like i need to
be serious about it but like
that's brought on an entirely different
i guess
layer of enjoyment that i otherwise
would have never experienced
and i don't know like i think it's
because as well like all the topics that
we cover of like you know the kind of
otaku
kind of stuff and like anime kind of
stuff where it's like yeah
doing it here as opposed to anywhere
else is just
i think completely different oh it
totally is like one one of the biggest
things i've like
realized this year is a lot of the
mystery
a lot of like the mystery and the
prestige not
not the prestige like the mystery around
like the anime industry itself
has kind of like it's it's i see the
anime industry totally different
because i remember before like i moved
here and you know you know
as as a teenager as a kid you think
maybe maybe i could like as a dream job
i could work in anime once yeah
but like you have no [ __ ] clue what
steps you need to take
like i thought you had to be like
incredibly [ __ ] lucky and like the
more i meet people who work in this
industry
the more i realized oh you just need to
be here yeah you know what i mean like
like you just need to be here and know
one person yeah and that's enough
and sometimes you could [ __ ] look up
a job on craigslist
sometimes you you know you just you
you're like teaching english or
something or something and you just
happen to be
in person you just happen to stumble
upon someone who has an opportunity it's
it's like
like the biggest advice i can i can give
now if you are interested in working in
the japanese anime industry it's just to
[ __ ] be here because it's like
i've been surprised at how like
sometimes even how low the bar of entry
is because it's like the bar of entry
seems to be
okay yeah university degree but that's
that's like the minimum you have to get
a visa but
aside from that it's just kind of being
here and just hanging around the right
definitely notice that
and i didn't think i just didn't think
it worked that way you know what i mean
i i thought it was just like closed off
to all kind of foreigners and anyone
else or it took like
years and years of building yourself
yeah yeah yeah and we go
you go to those anime studios and you
just meet a guy who's like i'm american
and then you are so how did you get how
did you get this job because it was like
you think you you think they just had
like the craziest [ __ ] journey
craigslist yeah yeah i mean yeah most of
the time it's just yeah i was just
teaching english and i just saw a job
posting for a random anime job and i
just
went for the interview and i'm just like
oh wait it was that easy this entire
time
did you even speak english it's
literally the mcdonald's method
like i see an ad i'll apply for a
[ __ ] why not yeah
get the job oh yeah oh okay i got the
job cool
yeah i don't know i i i guess totally
agree with that in terms of
all the mystique around it it's kind of
like slowly peeling away right right
but yeah i don't know it's it's hard to
summarize all my feelings
about living here and working here but
yeah definitely the structure has been
added
and i don't know if that's because of
japan or because of how we've
scheduled and built our work optimized
yeah yeah i mean
having an agency here uh that works with
us and works with anime has been
super helpful yeah um and has helped me
feel like a lot more
like you said structured because before
this uh
yeah i was just kind of [ __ ] around i
think and i was just hoping that the
checks kept coming in
yeah i was like i'll just keep making
stuff that i really enjoy it didn't feel
real
right yeah no and i assumed that every i
assumed that every year could be my last
yeah and now i'm starting to think okay
well you know if you know as long as i
don't do
[ __ ] anything stupid
as long as none of us get cancelled yeah
you know you know you're probably gonna
be around for
for a little a little bit right yeah you
can normally safely assume i've got a
year left in this
yeah right like you can probably
normally plan a year or two right and
and
you know and and some people like well
you know like
damn shouldn't you be working in like a
proper career and whatnot like what is a
proper career anymore like
bro some people like still dr like 50
years old driving ubers like is that a
career like yeah
why why people got to make a thing about
it it's just your prerogative right
like whatever makes you happier if
you're getting the money and it's making
you happy you're not hurting anybody i
think that's a proper career yeah
the way i see it as well is that like if
for some reason youtube falls through
you know in a year and i got nothing
left like hey man i've got experiences
people could like kill for right right
all three of us have been smart enough
to kind of establish ourselves
in you know fields outside of youtube
yeah
my plan my plan b used to be go back to
the bbc and get like uh go back into
engineering
and stuff but now like if youtube falls
through like i have a
like i have other plan b's of like other
businesses i could possibly get involved
in and that's like
it's gave me it's given me like in in a
career that really shouldn't have
the feeling of any kind of job security
i i do feel secure that yeah i do have
a specific skill set that working in
doing this has given me as opposed to
five years ago when i'm just like what
the [ __ ] can you learn doing youtube
yeah
you know what what the [ __ ] could i
actually learn how to edit a video
like like like you know when you you
look back and you start doing youtube
you just think what can i
possibly put on myself i'm getting
nothing out of this what can i possibly
put on my cv
right and then now you're like if in
terms of social media entertainment and
marketing it's like it's it's a big list
yeah yeah absolutely yeah i think i
think uh
you know a lot of people think is uh on
most youtubers
as uh you know like the [ __ ] dumb
people
dumb college dropouts i mean you do see
a lot of them who are like [ __ ] i'm in
the same category as him
yeah right but i think what people
understand
is that there are a lot of companies
that wish they had people who understood
those kind of like because a lot of
companies you'll see them man they don't
[ __ ] understand social media
and you know if you know if what if we
did lose our job there is a good chance
that we could probably work in
a company and be ahead of their social
media department or help with
strategizing right consulting
anything right i mean it's like dr
disrespect right he was an online
creator and then he went to work for
uh i think activision right or infinity
ward and he was the head of their
community relations
oh really yeah for a while oh wow before
before coming back to streaming yeah so
before he came back that's what
he left because he was a big cod
streamer i believe right right and then
he left to go and be there community
related uh community management or
something along social media
it speaks to even back then that someone
who had just been doing videos online
who seems very amateurish
yeah you know that knowledge that you
gain is so invaluable and companies wish
they understood that and they could hire
as many teams as they want but
right because it's so rare especially
for someone like you know disrespect to
like
reach numbers like that right it's not
something that you can like
it's not something that it's like well i
got a degree in it i studied it
therefore i'm gonna get results like
that just doesn't happen right
you learn a lot through youtube and i
think that even if you are doing it as a
hobby now
uh and you don't see any potential in it
i think the skills that you're learning
are really really
like useful skills i don't think you
realize useful yeah one one thing
one important skill that i had to learn
how to do is kind of
realizing what skills i thought were
useless and were actually not useless
and
it's actually thinking back to be like
oh yeah i do know how to do this thing
maybe this is
this is actually useful in some way
because it's it's like part of part of
part of making yourself look sellable as
a person to any employees
what skills have you have you got and
what like experience do you have
and what like we we grew up in like a
generation or at least like
especially with asian parents where we
were taught hey do well in tests
get like your degree go to university
and if you don't go to university you're
a [ __ ] dropout
yeah and you're scum you're not like
yeah yeah and
like the older they grow i grew up the
more i realized yeah if you have like
certain career options
and certain like career paths that you
want to go down yes a degree is
definitely you definitely need that but
if you kind of don't know what you want
to do yet that doesn't mean that every
other skill set you gain
is invaluable right you don't need a
degree to make a
plan b in your life right yeah it's like
i never i never learned
anything about like business or
marketing in school like i didn't take
any of those like classes i never did
any of that
yeah and i learned so much about that
kind of [ __ ] just from doing youtube
yeah and that's like a really valuable
skill to have but i didn't need to go to
school for it i just had to [ __ ]
do it yeah i just had to go through it
and experience it because it's the way i
see it right i have an engineering
degree yeah if you put me in an
engineering workplace
i wouldn't know [ __ ] yeah exactly i
don't know what's going on
maybe i you know i understand i
understand the rough concepts that make
up a lot of basic engineering and yeah
probably teach me a lot easier but you
couldn't just plop me in an office and
be like
do it yeah i would have no clue yeah
yeah at all because you have to learn
how that that company utilize that skill
right right right and and without using
it practically
it's like what am i doing i've just got
good at tests like
i was [ __ ] and i constantly got
frustrated because i never felt like i
was learning engineering although i
was i was learning the concept i felt
like a lot of it was so impractical
but i mean you were learning it through
your head but not through your body
right yeah i think i mean we weren't
using it yeah like
we learned it's like why this is
important they tell you but it's like
[ __ ] like have you guys ever had like
a proper real job interview
or anything like that yeah and it was
rough
well yeah was yours for mcdonald's
because no no
no no no no for like it was like like a
real job oh okay so like when i
before i decided to do youtube full-time
yeah uh i was actually still applying
for engineering
jobs because i was going to do a year in
placement right which is uh in
in i don't know if they do this in
australia you could basically after your
second year in the uk
oh you have an in industry yeah yeah
basically working yeah you get paid to
work and you normally it's normally
those kids do really well in third year
as well because they come into it with a
lot more like like an internship right
practical experience yeah
like kind of like an internship yeah
yeah an internship that actually pays
well and
you normally get a job after it like out
there normally normally they
you get the job offer for that's
placement after your like year ends
and some of them might even offer to pay
for the third year and the masters
so it's like it's kind of like no
downside to doing it especially
engineering right it's really good the
hardest part is getting an offer in the
first place
it's really hard to get a good place to
take you yeah i remember i did tests for
like
rolls-royce and stuff and they were hard
like they were making
every single one of them it was so
annoying you would apply for it and
they'd make you do this in
like an hour and a half long test that
was hard as [ __ ]
yeah and eventually you just got to the
point where you're like i've done four
of these
in one day and it took all day and i
know i'm not gonna get any of them
yeah let's be honest i'm not smart
enough to work in rolls-royce's jet
engine
i'm just gonna be honest dude that ain't
me you know and i
i had an interview for one and i i just
remember them asking me questions and
i'm like
[ __ ] i can't even like stomach the lies
i i can't even
i can't even i don't even have the you
didn't even have the business
yeah i care so little about actually
getting this job
that i couldn't even sit there and lie
to the guy yeah like i would in a normal
job interview i would be like of course
yeah i i never really like worked any
job
like before youtube became a job i mean
like i told the story of how i tried for
mcdonald's and failed and then
i think i did one internship like during
uni but at that point like
youtube was kind of becoming more of a
priority that i knew i probably wasn't
gonna go into this field
anyway yeah but like i'm not gonna say
the company name but like
last like two years or so i've been
approached by this like
relatively big company like yeah
international that like really wanted me
oh okay and that was the first time
where i went into like an actual like
proper job interview yeah but i didn't
do one interview
i did 17 interviews holy [ __ ] not to
mention
i did some here in japan and then i also
did some
in l.a 18. yeah i can help i did some in
la so like when i was like staying at
aki's place in vegas
and they like flew me out to la just to
do like six more interviews oh my god
well then i had to fly back and uh at
the end of the day
i didn't get the job so i was like
really fun but like i'd like to think
that after the 16th interview they were
like you know i don't think so but
let's try one more time and it was like
a different person every time
as well yeah so like but but this is
like a pretty big comment like i'm
pretty sure i'm not allowed to say who
but like it was a pretty big company
yeah and uh
and and it was like it was a company as
well that i was really interested in as
well because it's like oh like if
youtube falls through
this is a perfect place to work yeah
like hell yeah like this is my plan b
and so i was genuinely excited to be
like maybe i might get this job i don't
know and then
yeah but yeah it was just [ __ ] but i
think that just made it so much more
stressful
yeah i remember oh sorry because it was
like because i was genuinely interested
but it's like
how do i like tell that to the person
without sending like an absolute kiss
ass
you know yes i love everything you do of
course i want to work for you if you've
got that job would you have quit youtube
hard to say wow i can't say now that
with the place you're at on youtube i
remember
every person in their youtube careers
thought maybe i'll get a proper job
because i don't know when this will fall
yeah right
it was it was at that point where i was
like i give myself a little bit there's
a lot of anxiety and a lot of
uh what's the word like you you don't
trust it
yeah like you don't think you think it's
temporary yeah even though you know it's
not yeah there's always that gut feeling
and then i think i can understand
sometimes why
you know some people youtubers want to
move on and want to do something else
yeah i understand that
i don't have that interest right now and
i don't want to move on cause i'm really
enjoying it
but you know i could i can i'm starting
to understand after doing this for like
five years
i can understand the mindset of why
someone wouldn't want to be in that
coin flip every day is like well let's
see if i've got a job today
right yeah it is kind of like it is
really stressful to
and i think that i've just become used
to it yeah but if you put someone in
this situation overnight i feel like
it's one of those things where it's like
oh they wouldn't be able to handle it
maybe not handle it but it would
definitely it would definitely wear on
you
oh yeah absolutely going back to job
interviews i do have like a story of
like my
very first i'd say real job interview
because you know i
i've had job interviews for like co-op
and like call centers and stuff
we're talking like they just want to
make sure you're not a [ __ ] criminal
exactly all you have to do
is just be a competent person and
somehow joey can couldn't even be that
for his mcdonald's interview but
that's that's a different story but like
we're talking actual like big boy
companies okay
you're here for a specific skill set so
this is like before i got my job at the
bbc so
as you do as a graduate you apply to
about 10 [ __ ]
10 million different companies you just
hope one of them sticks yeah so
one uh one company that actually um
called me back for an interview was a
missile company
so i would basically be kind of like
yeah yeah like what other missiles are
there joey
i don't know it just sounded really
weird it's like a company that makes
missiles like what sound missiles make
so yeah what would you do yeah i design
get down the missiles are coming
but yeah it was a it was a proper
missile company and i was
uh applying to be like a systems
engineer to like design and make
missiles
so like obviously i go in the i go in
the interview and
i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] nailing this
interview okay i i i can't i can't
remember i can't remember how it is like
like the interview was split up into two
different segments right like there was
the one where like they
like into your like personality and i
don't know i can't remember what that's
called no there's a technical term
yeah there's there's there's one whether
like they you know they grill you about
you know what
why why do you why do you think you'd be
a good fit for this company
you say you're a [ __ ] team player
yeah you're a perfectionist to uh
one of my weaknesses oh well you know i
just uh i'm i just
um i love money i love money i i am a
perfectionist and you can't [ __ ] say
look i just need money
and i need to pay off my [ __ ] student
loan why are you asking me questions
that you know the [ __ ] answer to okay
so but like i i breeze through that and
i know i know
they've i know i'm doing a good [ __ ]
job right and then i get to the
technical interview
and the technical interview i actually
prepared for this right because
you know i'm working for a [ __ ] i'm
applying to be a [ __ ] missile
designer so i should probably know the
basics of how
a missile works right and sure enough i
get to the technical interview
and they ask me um so can you explain
the
broad basics about how a missile works
right
and so they go
no so um i've mentioned this before but
my degree is in electronic and
electrical engineering so
i was um so basically this this was this
was going to be a breeze for me i know
how a missile works so
i've done my research yeah yeah yeah and
so
um i start so there's two interviewers
there's one
older serious guy and then there's one
like younger not exactly a grad
graduate he's been there a few years but
he's like he's like at the time he was
like
late 20s early 30s yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly so
i start like i start explaining how this
missile works so there's like a
whiteboard
and like so i draw i draw the missile
right
and and i'm like i'm like explaining
explaining explaining everything i'm
like yeah together this system does this
this isn't on this
and so my final year degree project
my thesis story was on like object real
time object tracking and everything like
that so perfect perfect for what i need
to
explain here so i start explaining how
this missile
like tracks different objects so i draw
this rectangle
and i label that target and then i draw
a dotted line
from the target to like this missile
that i've drawn
right and so i started explaining okay
this is how the tracking system works
and the tracking system is in the front
of this missile and so i cordoned off
the front of this missile
right and i'm [ __ ] getting into this
i'm like okay so this is this is how
this is how my experience with my
tracking degree can can like
help with how i can explain like how i'm
missing myself right yeah i'm [ __ ]
telling myself
i'm getting into it and then i look over
and then
like the older serious guy was just like
hmm yes variance where and then the
younger guy
was like trying to hold his laughter he
was just like
oh no what did you draw on the rocket
gone
and and then and then i look over i'm
like and i'm thinking to myself like
why are you laughing at what i'm doing
i'm on i'm killing this
i'm [ __ ] killing this my career is on
the line here
i just want to get a job what he what
could you possibly be laughing at
and then i look at what i've drawn i've
drawn a penis
how how did you draw a piece i've i've
drawn a big
girthy penis pissing on a rectangle
and how how did you do that i've
actually i've actually got a picture
right
i've i've got to show you this i was
really hoping this story's climax would
be a bad opinion yeah i was i was
thinking when he was like
drawing on him yeah this this this is
but like i didn't realize how much it
looked like a [ __ ] penis
until that's a straight up johnny
it is a [ __ ] girthy face
as soon as i saw that as soon as i saw
that right
i knew i failed not because not because
i was doing a bad job
but you know when you're in the zone and
like
and like there's not there's nothing
that could take me out of the zone
knowing that i've just drawn a [ __ ]
penis into in front of two examinees
and then after that i just start
stumbling and i forget everything i
prepared
right you failed that time yeah yeah
you didn't get it i didn't get it
they specifically said that i did super
super well on my like the personality
side of things
but uh the technical side was lacking
i had totally blocked out of my mind
that there was a they ask you technical
questions
because i think i was so [ __ ] bad at
it right yeah because i remember i
had a question uh and it was asking me
like they were asking me like how
turbines work i knew how they worked
yeah but you know when you're in a room
with like two really old men who've been
doing this for years and they ask it
like they're like
how do you [ __ ] tell me how you [ __ ]
describe how you [ __ ] what
it's like it's like i know how to shoot
but when they're looking at me like that
and they're asking me that way i'm like
ah
so um yeah the blades uh take the oxygen
in and they mix it with
am i right is this right this is right
yeah [ __ ] you know i remember i just
butchered it yeah
but also did you ever do video
interviews but you did but there's no
one to talk to
what video interviews well i got skype
so yeah
so if you passed the test right uh the
math test
and personality right they would say
that you wouldn't get an interview
you got a video video interview where
all you could see is yourself
yeah oh no i never had that but that
sounds horrible i i've never had that i
mean
i was like three times three times right
and
it was like so basically what it was is
that would be
uh it [ __ ] felt like a mario [ __ ]
party quick time event
it would be there would be a slide right
where you could see yourself and it
would cut to a question
and then it would be like five four and
then you have to answer it and they will
film it
it was terrifying like one of them was
like so
stupid it was like so it you know it's
going and it's like you know
okay and then it was like who's your
biggest engineering inspiration and i'm
like
[Laughter]
i don't [ __ ] know my engineering idol
i'm like i just did this for the degree
i don't think about this [ __ ] i'm trying
to play card like what do you mean
like and so i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] uh uh
uh uh i said like einstein or something
and i'm not
i'm like basic [ __ ]
i'm not kidding right i said einstein
right i finished that question and
that's the the
the next [ __ ] thing is two of seven
questions the next thing i just [ __ ]
all f4 i'm like
i haven't got this einstein
i was the most famous engineer in the
world
you might have heard of him because i
was like there's no way i'm getting it
with an answer like that
but that's asking what's your favorite
meal white bread i love it
i love white bread it keeps people
who [ __ ] needs the rest of the
questions have you guys ever had like
group interviews
no no i remember i i had one and
like so this was like the second company
that i applied to
and we had like a team team team
building interview
right that sounds horrible already yeah
and so our first task
was we were grouped up with another
person and i will never forget this
person
even though he's a [ __ ] genius but
i'll get to that later but like
um but like so our uh
so they were work they were gonna look
it out like our team building so
the very first task right was very
simple so
we get paired with someone and we had to
like learn as much
information about them as we can you
know like names hobbies yadda yadda
and then we'd have to like present that
to the group right as like
i'm sure that you saw it as an
icebreaker and everything but you know
the worst way testing out like
communication skills and listening
skills and all the basic [ __ ]
teamworking stuff you want to do
so i get i get paired up um with dan
thank you dan so like so
like we get paired up and immediately he
just goes hey my name my name's dan so
here's how you want to do it like i'll
say whatever i want to say about you and
you just say it's right and
you say whatever you want to say about
me and i'll just say it's right
you know so we don't have to worry about
this stupid icebreaker i'm just like
genius genius gigabrain so like
goes to our turn he starts he starts
talking and he's you know
he gets my name right but he just
[ __ ] makes up everything else about
me
like i like absolutely i like i like to
play fifa
that's so smart my favorite like my
favorite film is like i can't remember
what you [ __ ] said back there
yeah and so then it gets to my turn and
i'm like hey this is
dan he loves fifa no like uh yeah he's
uh
he's x years old he's like he's like 23
years old and he's like nah
22. i'm like no yo yo are you [ __ ]
doing this right now genius
are you [ __ ] doing is he is it is he
really [ __ ] me over like this right
now
and i started i say yeah i know he likes
to play call of duty no i don't like
playing call of duty
wow top 10 was just like
you [ __ ] you are [ __ ] me over
even though it's [ __ ] genius because
i am your competition
i [ __ ] hate you right now but i can't
hate you because i should have thought
of this oh that's some
[ __ ] movie villain
i couldn't place someone like that
that's too hard holy [ __ ]
this this man was playing [ __ ] 5d
chess in the middle it's cute [ __ ]
hell
i [ __ ] hope you got the job like
jesus christ could you imagine if you
did get the job after all that he just
[ __ ] you over for no reason
[Music]
hey man doggy dog world i respect that
i learned i learned i learned a harsh
lesson that day and i will never forget
it there you go uni graduates
[ __ ] of your opponents but that does
seem like the kind of thing where it's
like that's too good to be true and
someone else brings it to you right yeah
yeah yeah
son of a [ __ ] that's [ __ ] dead keep
keep your enemies close
yeah goddamn wow on that note that's
been this episode
of the trash taste i guess hey look at
all these patrons though
yeah beautiful people who support this
this guy wouldn't [ __ ] me over in a job
interview
i hope dan was actually like danny
but yeah if you'd like to support the
show then you can do so by going over to
trash
patreon also follow us on the subreddit
and the twitter as usual also listen to
us over on spotify links to that down in
the description below
that's hell yeah and uh what else we
want to shout out thank you to everyone
who just joined our subreddits have you
already shout out our twitter eyes
completely
i did all of that okay i was just like
joey's saying words and i'm just like
wait
is it my time to speak what am i
supposed to say now i got your color
editing by mood very epic very nice very
nice
yes thank you very much thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you